so we're supposedly live
exciting
i will uh maybe see if i can fill it up
on youtube and check
okay we are live
cool
you
all right so i guess it's time to get
started so welcome to those of you
watching uh to the catalyst.jl workshop
um before we get started i just wanted
to mention that we're going to be going
through some
pluto notebooks we put together kind of
presenting to you some features of
catalyst and they're all up on the web
so i just wanted to show you very
briefly how you could get them and load
them in case you want to actually have
the code running while you watch
so let me
uh
share my
web browser hopefully
um
so if you go
to the catalyst jl website which will i
need to make that font a lot bigger uh
so you can just google catalyst.jl
um
there is a link in the readme
uh
that both to the pigeonhole where you
can go if you want to ask questions and
there's also a link to where we've
posted our pluto notebooks
and so this is the the repo that has our
notebooks and what you want to do if you
want to actually load them and follow
along using them
live is you want to just download this
you can download it as a zip file
save it somewhere on your computer
and navigate to whatever folder use
wherever you save that in my case i've
got it saved um
let me show you where i've got it see
well i'll leave it up navigate to
wherever you've got it saved
and start julia there
and then within julia um
when you're within the root folder that
has this project.tomol and
manifest.tomol in it just load the using
package activate it instantiate it
um now you may wait a little while
because it's going to pull down and load
all the packages and compile them
run pluto and
basically that'll pull up your web
browser and at that point you can start
navigating into the tutorial folder and
opening the various tutorials that we're
going to go through
so that's a way you can kind of follow
along and hopefully that works for
everyone it should be self-contained as
long as you make sure to run these
commands in the root folder where the
manifest and project are located
so okay so with that said uh let's start
the workshop
so let me just open back up my
presentation
um
okay
so we're like i said we're going to tell
you about catalyst.jl today
um and um
maybe torkle maybe you could post in the
pigeonhole the the link to just the
catalyst website to get the stuff for
people coming in late
yep
thank you um so uh i'm sam isaacson and
uh uh torkel uh is is my uh uh
co-presenter here with me today uh we're
two of the developers for catalyst.jl um
chris rakakus has also done a lot of
development on it um in fact he created
the original version of it which was
difficult way back in the day i believe
it was chris maybe it was chris and
torkle um
and a lot of people have helped out with
adding features like yingbo and shashi
and some others so i just wanted to
mention them and mention that we've got
several um
uh sponsors for siamel and catalyst via
chan zuckerberg and welcome and people
supporting us on github and so we very
much appreciate all that support it's
allowed me to do a lot more work on it
this year during my sabbatical and
hopefully future support will let us
keep working on these kinds of projects
um
so we're mainly going to be going
through pluto networks to show you how
to do stuff in catalyst today but i
wanted to give you maybe a eight or nine
minute overview of kind of what catalyst
is and how we're going to use it
before we get into actually kind of
going through the details
so catalyst.jl is a modeling toolkit
based symbolic representation for
chemical reaction systems so it creates
something called the reaction system
which stores a symbolic representation
of chemical reaction networks um
it also includes a domain specific
language for kind of concisely entering
reaction systems into julia
and then
from that language these symbolic
reaction systems are produced and so
here i've got a little example that
probably looks complicated but we'll be
going through much simpler ones in
building up to this today um of the
repressolator and how you could type it
in into catalyst and then on the right
there's just a little graph that
catalyst can for example generate um
that shows the reaction complex network
associated with this reaction system
the kinds of things that we can end
input into catalyst and we want to study
with it um
so one of catalyst's main features is
that it can take your symbolic reaction
system and convert it into symbolic
modeling toolkit uh reaction rate
equation ode systems or symbolic
chemical longivin sde systems in
modeling toolkit or symbolic jump
systems that represent stochastic
chemical kinetics models and allow you
to then simulate those reaction rate
equation odes or that jump process very
easily and again we'll show you how to
do this very shortly
so that's one of its main most beautiful
features is just
specifying very easily your reaction
system and then generating and solving
the corresponding mathematical model but
catalyst also has a bunch of extra
features than just that so we have a
pretty comprehensive api at this point
part at this point that lets you do
things like network analysis so if you
want to calculate stoichiometry matrices
or linkage classes of your network or
the deficiency of your network or
whether your network is reversible or
weakly reversible we have functionality
for that um one cool thing which
hopefully we will have time to show you
later today is the catalyst can detect
and eliminate conservation laws from
networks
so that's a way you can reduce the size
of system and say make jacobians of
systems uh non-singular and that's
something we'll come back to
um catalyst lets you do compositional
modeling where you can say specify a
model for a gene a model for another
gene and then compose them together into
a larger model for a gene network
it also lets you do more than just
chemical reaction modeling you can
couple your chemical reaction models to
constraint odes or algebraic equations
and i'll show you some examples of that
later today and more recently we've
added the ability to have parametric
stoichiometry which lets us do things
like have bursty chemical reactions
catalyst also by design is meant to be
able to compose well with other julia
and sci-ml libraries so that you can use
it to do sensitivity analysis of your
network or optimization or parameter
estimation and also so you can
incorporate other types of models into
catalyst be it surrogate models or
machine learning based models or plug
catalyst into those workflows itself
so what are we actually going to go
through today and this is my last slide
before we'll actually start showing you
kind of how catalyst works in at the
julia level at the code level the first
kind of portion of our
workshop is going to be kind of an
introduction to catalyst how do we build
ode sde jump process models how do we
use this domain specific language to
enter the models in
what's catalyst actually doing under the
hood when you take one of these dsl
models and and then just solve odes with
it kind of what's the process that's
going on there and give you some
guidance about how you can say optimize
simulations to some degree how you can
add extra features in like calculating
jacobians of ode models or making sure
that you're using the most optimized
jump process simulation algorithm
stochastic simulation algorithm for your
particular model so that's kind of the
first portion maybe the first half of
our workshop
and then the circuit second part we have
a bunch of stuff which maybe we'll get
through it all and maybe we won't that
kind of goes into some of the more
advanced features of catalyst and these
include things like how you can model
bursty reactions by having parametric
stoichiometry that lets you say have a
random variable as a stoichiometric
coefficient how we can combine multiple
reaction models together reaction system
models into larger ones how we can add
constraint odes or algebraic equations
with the specific example that i'll show
you today of how to build a
hodgkin-huxley neuron model
um
torkle will show us about how we can use
combined catalysts with bifurcation kit
to look at bifurcation analysis of
chemical reaction networks and how we
can combine it with homotopy
continuation to find all the steady
states of a mass-action reaction system
um and then if there's time at the end i
want to show you a little bit about how
we can do conservation law analysis to
reduce the network
to make it more amenable for use with
tools like bifurcation kit or homotopic
continuation
okay so that was kind of the quick and
dirty kind of introduction to today's
presentation and i think torquel is
taking over now right
yeah
so i will try to
share my slides
and
sorry
oh
okay uh just checking that
people can see this
and if you can't see anything youngst
someone warned me before we get too deep
into the presentation
and said idea like what i want to do is
just having a very brief introduction of
how to make a simulation using catalyst
model so really like the main part of
the package is that you create your
biochemical reaction network model and
then create a simulation
and we're going to have like more
advanced tutorials on how to do that
later on
and there will be like a big section
actually creating the models but since
this is the main feature of the package
i feel i just want to show this off
directly in the beginning so you know
where we're getting it
and so the first step if you want to do
is you actually want to create your
model
uh
and the main way or like the few ways to
do it but one is to use this at reaction
network macro and and this is something
which catalyst implements which is a dsl
domain specifically sorry to interrupt
just so you know you didn't you weren't
sharing the slides i just shared them
for you
ah okay uh
excellent
um
now they're gonna pursue now they're
removed okay okay yeah yeah okay yeah i
see um
we'll try to
uh
make another try um
can you see them now
you haven't shared they're not wait no
yeah i remember i remember yeah i'd add
them to the window exactly
uh
add to stream okay excellent now it
should work yeah yeah there was a step
to the streaming platform which i forgot
about okay
uh
so basically the first step is create
your model uh we have a few different
ways to do this uh and we'll go through
in more detail
one is that um
i'm gonna
i'm gonna it's a little small so i'm
gonna just go put it on full screen is
that okay yeah yeah okay uh all right
that sounds good
that means that no one can see me right
uh
which might be a good thing anyway sorry
i will try to not make any important
gestures okay
can people see my karcher by the way
i've probably checked this before
yes
excellent okay
so there's like really two main ways to
create a model
and one is to use this domain specific
language
and the second one sam will go through
more in detail afterwards
and here i will focus on just you create
your model using that reaction network
uh macro and then you just list
all of the reaction events you have in
your system so here i create a normal
birth def process which is that you have
a single species of the system x
uh this could be for example like
chemical species but it could also be if
you model say a population dynamics uh
some kind of animal
and then you say like we have a birth
process we go from nothing so the zero
denotes the empty set
two you get one species x and this
happens on rate b
and then you have a def event
where you go from having x to having
nothing and this happens at rate d
and then i create this simple birth def
process model and i save it in variable
bd model
and next what we can do is that we can
do mainly three different types of
simulations so we can make this ordinary
differential equation simulations
and typically this is a good
approximation to make when
concentrations of your species are very
high so you don't have to care about
stochastic effects and really what you
then have to do you just have to specif
specify the basics you have to specify
some kind of initial condition
uh where do we wish to start the
simulation
you have to specify a time span uh so
which time period we want to simulate
here from 0 to 50.
and then we have to set the parameter
values of our model and here we have two
parameters where b
and we have d so the birth rate and
death rate
and you bundle all of this up into an od
problem
so the model the initial condition the
time span and the parameter value
and then you can solve with using the
sole command
and then you plot your solution here
so all kinds of simulations uh we do
using the differential equations package
uh and i think probably a fair amount
you're very familiar with this and the
syntax to simulating using a catalyst
model and using a normal function using
differential equations is pretty much
the same so here we just
have our bd model instead of having the
differential equation function
and
next what you can do if you have to
account for stochastic effects you can
use uh stochastic differential equation
simulations
and this use the chemical launch of
inner approximation if you want to be
technical about it but in essence it
adds natural noise to the system
and here the only difference is instead
of creating an od problem we create an
sd problem
and then we can solve it and we can plot
it and we see we get something similar
but we have these fluctuations to the
system
so we smoothly go from the initial
condition to a steady state
and here we see
we get this
noisy solution instead
and finally what you might have at some
points
is that you make a jump process
simulation or gillespie simulation and
here we actually keep track on the exact
number of x pieces in our system
so here again
we set an initial condition a initial
condition
uh and we know that one difference here
is that
we're going to have uh an integer number
x
so if you look here previously uh
two slides back at one point zero so
this is a float because we have
continuous concentrate concentration but
here we want to track the integral
number of how many x molecules do we
have in the system
and then instead we're going to use the
two we create a discrete problem it's
just the same
then we set a jump problem
and then we can simulate it
and then we can see here how the amount
of x pieces in the system can evolves in
these discrete jumps will go from one to
three to four
probably two jumps here in very close
proximity
and sam will go through all of the
details how to make these jump
simulations later on
and this is really like the essence in
catalyst is that
you
create your model
and then you simulate it with whatever
approach is appropriate for your
application
and now we'll go to the next uh
part of the presentation and here i will
really go into detail of this dsl
so the domain specific language
uh
we're allowed to create models using
this macro thing
and they're really too like as i said
there are two main ways to create your
models either you would use this dsl we
can use these nice uh notations
but the sam will show you can also
programmatically create so you like
specify directly direction events
and advantage with that is that you have
a little bit more control over your
model and maybe you want to do
modifications of it
and this is really more advantageous if
you
quick and dirty you just want to get
your system a model as quickly as
possible
and then this allows you to very quickly
create a model and then have access to a
lot of different simulations
so again
you want to declare that you want to use
this dsl with the add reaction network
macro so the macro then allows you to
use custom codes in julia
and then you have the begin end block
and here you're going to have on each
line you're going to have one reaction
event uh torquel did you switch did you
switch to a new window but not update
the stream because it's still showing
your first presentation
very good very good
let's see here so
hmm
oh yeah no went yeah okay i think i know
what happens uh it's good that sam keeps
track on things here
uh so i have to
probably stop the screen
and then i'm gonna share share the
screen
application oh yeah now i can do it like
this
okay
and then
i'm gonna add it up there i added it for
you it's it's up
excellent okay uh can you see things now
okay so
there shouldn't be too many more
transitions so hopefully uh we won't
have too much of these technical
problems anymore okay
so fortunately we asked on the first
slide uh of the next set of
presentations uh but this is really
where i want to go through like this dsl
this macro and how to use these chemical
reaction notations to create your models
and as i said here the model object you
just say the variable in which you want
to save your model
at reaction networks declares that here
something funny is going to happen
and then you have this begin end block
and here on each line
you can have one reaction event
and each reaction event takes a set of
species
and turns them into a different set of
species
and this could for example be i mean in
this case we have a simple production
event where sierra denotes nothing and
here we get an x
uh and for example if you have if you're
modeling a chemistry you might have a
binding event we have two molecules
binding to each other forming a new
molecule
if you're modeling population dynamics
you might have a birth event we have one
rabbit with birth to another rabbit
or
more complicated you actually have two
rabbits giving birth to one rabbit or if
you're modeling an epidemic so you could
model this disease threat you can have
an
infected individual meets a healthy
individual on one side and the other
side you have two infected individuals
and then here b which is the rate that
this happens
uh
so how uh for example here you have a
birth rate
from turning nothing to x and here we
have the death rate so this is the same
model i used for example last one
and here we see that the model can get
displayed using this nice
chemical reaction notation as well which
looks quite similar here so i have a
birth reaction and a depth reaction to
create a single species x
and then there's this package latexify
which you can use to take this model and
then display the differential equation
so here we have the ordinary
differential equation
for the rate of change in x we get using
this model and we save our constant
production b
and then we have
death rate which is this d rate times
the concentration of x
uh
so slightly more advanced of course
uh
in previous i only had one species here
so or nothing
but you can have several species for
example here we have dimerization model
where we have two x molecules which bind
at some binding rate and form as a
single molecule x2
and then we have the association event
with this x2 molecule turns into 2x
and here you can see that i simply add
this coefficient before
to to denote that a 2x molecule that
participates in this event
and we can see here this reaction that
we have 2x binds forming x square 2
and then we have to see a dissociation
where we get
2x again
and here again we can display the
ordinary differential equations
and here we get slightly different
things that happens
and i think
sam will actually go through
very much how this is calculated but the
important thing here you see
that if you look at the previous one
here we see that if we have nothing here
the
rate is just this constant
if we have one x here we get the
concentration of x times d so this makes
sense uh if we have twice as many
individuals
i expect to see twice as many depth
events whenever within every time unit
now here instead we have two x molecules
not one
and then we see the rate of this
reactions we see how many x molecule
gets removed is actually x squared times
the binding rate so we can see that
uh the rate of change in x is x square
times the binding rate
and then where plus this thing where we
have the concentration of x2
times kd
so the rate of dissociation reaction
and then times two because each of these
reaction events you're not producing
only one x molecule but two x molecules
and then the perceptive automotive said
that actually like here in each binding
event you actually lose two x molecules
should be a two
here so the minus two x squared akb
which is the case but there's also a
half
uh so in principle we have something x
squared you have to account for
uh
this extra coefficient which is
basically one divided by two faculty
uh which becomes one two
and here i have a slightly more
artificial example yes to show that i
can have several different species in
one so i say i have two x molecules
there and three y molecules and then i
just write 2x plus 3y and then here i
get get
a produce a single set
and then we can see the rate here for
the production of set is that of case we
have the rate r
we have the x to the power of two
because we're two x molecules times y to
the power of three
and then these coefficients becomes one
divided by three times two plus one so
free faculty
this symbol
and then
so wonder by the six times uh
sorry no lost uh one divided by 6 times
1 divided by 2 so becomes 1 divided by
12.
but yeah in principle you never actually
have to see these equations so one nice
thing for catalyst is that you just
write what reaction events you have
and then the equations are generated you
can look at what and what you want but
you never have to actually deal with
that mode you simulate your model
and especially if you're looking at
stochastic differential equations we
jump
this is a great relief because the noise
terms gets quite extensive
and
and this is really like the base of
using the macro
or the dsl
and one main feature having this dsl is
just that it should be as simple to use
as possible and you like you want to use
it when you want to create a model as
quickly as possible and effortlessly and
to do this we have
a couple of extra features uh
just to simplify notation
and i'm just now going to show off these
ones
so one for example uh we created this
birthday
model but we see here actually this we
have one single reaction going two ways
so we go from nothing to x but we also
go from x to nothing
as where b turns 0 to x and d
rate turn x to zero
and we can actually simplify this
so here we turn 0 to x but we have this
arrow to show that it's a reversible
reaction so we have four over rate zero
to x and the backward rate to backward
direction x to zero
and then we have to use this tuple thing
and
to show direction rate where the first
element here is the forward rate so b
above parameter will go from nothing to
x and d the death rate we go from x to
zero
and i should probably also note that uh
after you have this n command here what
you would do is you list all of the
parameters
and this helps the
system figure out which symbols here are
parameters and which are species and
we'll get to why this is important later
on
and then we can check if these models
are the same
and yes they are so declaring the bond
like this like this doesn't really
matter
and i should add here
and this is a little bit
very tangential but here i had an
additional argument between art reaction
network and begin and this kind of sets
the name of the model
uh
and the reason i do this is that
i just want these two to have different
names to the like true command but if
you want you can like have different
names here
and this is really a parenthesis but i'm
saying this because some people might
see that i have this extra argument
here and i won't do that later on
another thing you can do is that you can
bundle reactions that are very similar
so say for example here i have a buff
test process where i produce both on
species x and the species y
and they both degrade as well so this is
just a buff death
model
by two instances
and we can see here that i have two very
similar birth events and two very
similar death events
and i can set again by using tattoos
here so a single rate b
both reactions have the same substrate
so like the initial you start with
nothing
and then they go to x and y
and by using this tuple here
i denote that i want to split this in
different directions
uh so this thing here becomes indeed
identical to this thing here
in the same way i can bundle up the
degradation events using this temple so
here i'm gonna have two reactions both
reactions gonna have the same rate
the same product
uh but input the substrates uh there are
two alternatives one is x and y is one
is y
so here this reaction uh
gets split into this one
and especially with uh degradation
events when i make my own model i will
notice i might have like seven different
species in my system and they're all
gonna degrade at the same rate so
they're gonna have uh
one and that's gonna save me having
seven different lines for the
degradation reactions i can just write
one like this
and this makes models look a lot cleaner
um
yeah
yeah we see these are just um
oh yeah
so another thing you can do is uh
here these two reactions are only
different in the product uh but maybe i
hear cases where i have two buff
reactions and they also have different
rates so one rate both x and one right
birth y for the two both events
and again i can like create a bundling
here where say i'm going to have two
different reactions with two different
birth rates b x and b y
your actions gonna have the same uh
substrate input and two different
products
and then this is going to pick
this rate this substrate
this product for one reaction creating
this one and then this rate this
substrate and this product creating the
second reaction
and then again i'm gonna have the same
bonding of the degradation events
now it's also possible uh here we note
that this is also a reversible reaction
and we can see that here
i just have one reaction this way and
one reaction that way
and i can bundle even further see here i
have a reverberation reaction we go from
nothing to x or y but we also go the
other way
and then i have to uh
layer my or nest my tuples
so here i'm going to have the forward
rate and we can see that
that in turn is a tuple because
there are two different rates
and then we have a backward rate like
that
and i think maybe
it's probably better to declare your
model this way so like one thing like
it's nice to save a cut a line of code
but i think one thing that's really nice
with the dsl
is that it allows you to write code we
can look at the code and it's very easy
to see what kind of model you have
and if you start to like bundle things
and to be too efficient with space
it starts to get difficult to see what
actually happens
and i think maybe in this case this is
the level of model which is easy to like
see what's going on
but but it's up to the user if you want
to bundle things up very much you can do
it
uh and next
so
it's very general what you're gonna put
in your reaction rate so the rate of a
reaction scale is linear whatever you
put here
and previously i've just used one
parameter system b or d
but you can be very general what you put
here sarah try putting b divided by d
so you can have some expression of
several parameters you can just have a
constant for example one here
and you can also have functions so maybe
i declare a function bar for b is equal
to b square i'm not sure why i would do
this but i can
and then set
birth or b here
model and then i can see actually like
now we get the same death rate but the
birth rate is going to be b squared
uh
and i think like even people been able
to like you can put a neural network
here and stuff so this is very very
general
one thing which you probably want to use
is
you can have species concentrations here
so it's quite common that for example
the rate at which a reaction occur
not only depends on a parameter
but on species of the system
so for example one
case would be
if you have population growth
so then you would have uh you know don't
have constant production of rabbits but
the number of rabbits you produce
depends on how many rabbits you already
have
and then you might get something like
here that'll go from nothing to one x
for example one rabbit
and the rate is gonna be
the amount of the species x
and then like the def might also depend
i mean i already said like so
if i have twice as many individual
expect twice as many death events
but the rate that you die might also
depend on the population for example you
might have a carrying capacity so
there's lots and lots of rabbits there's
lots of competition for the food
and then you expect the death rate to
increase
so i have death rate times uh the amount
of rabbits and then we check this model
we're going to see that we get a
production of x which is equal to number
of x
linear production and then with this
quadratic
def term
and this is the logistic growth model
which some of you might be familiar with
now i'm interested in biochemical
reaction network and one common example
you have here is that you have some kind
of catalyst which also happened to be
where the name
of the package come from
and what the catalyst does is that you
have some kind of reaction
and this makes the reaction much easier
to do
and i think the motivation behind the
name is that catalyst makes modeling
much easier so here we see we have some
substrate which is times some product
and the rate depends on our parameter k
but also on
some species c
[Music]
and now here comes slightly important
detail is that
if i were to display the equations of
this system well we can see that
the rate at which s disappear of course
is equal to the amount of s the amount
of the catalyst
and this constant k and with the same
production rate p here
however
because i have not listed c
as a parameter at the end so the only
parameter said only k is a parameter
everything else here is a species so
even though c is not part of a reaction
like this
uh this is the more catalyst is going to
say that this is going to be a species
and here i see i have this thing here
where we have
uh dc dt is equal to zero so you're
gonna have a species uh but this is
never gonna change
uh
so this is gonna be constant all of the
time which might be a consideration
uh now maybe a more natural way to write
this uh is going to say that
okay catalyst is a part of direction c
is a part of direction which is neither
consumed or degraded so we have a
reaction occurring rate k
which takes s and c and turn it to p
plus c
and and here we can note uh so this is a
different way to write the same system
we can see we get exactly the same
equations here
now one thing you might want to do is to
say that actually
if c is going to be zero at the time
it's never going to change maybe i set
this as a parameter of the system so
then i can at least see here and it
displays the equations
and i see that
c here is not a function of time
and c never changes it's not a variable
of the system
and one thing this might be note uh
one argument to do every once in a while
especially with a lot of parameters that
you forget to list a parameter here so
here i have a two-state model we go from
a state x to a state y and back and
forth
our trade k
k x and k y
but i forget to list ky among my
parameters
and then we see that uh
okay i forgot the equation here
but oh yeah here you see see here you
see that we actually got another species
a k y
so here we're going to have even though
i think i have a system with two
parameters and two variables i'm gonna
have a system with three variables and
one parameter and this is probably gonna
generate the arrow down the line when i
try to do
simulations
now
one thing which might be interesting and
sam is going to go through this later on
that if you use the more advanced if you
don't keep using the dsl
but
mess a little bit modern toolkit stuff
of things you're actually able to like
figure out how can i designate whenever
the things in my system is a species
or
or a variable or a parameter
uh in my election makes sense that you
won't see to be a species uh but if you
don't very concerned with computational
performance maybe you don't want to like
even if nothing happens here it might
make things a little bit slower if the
system tried to like calculate
c rate of change in every time step even
though nothing happens
and it's possible to specify this later
on but this is the kind of things that
you want to do
maybe you don't want to use this dsl
type notation
so i said before
i model biochemistry
and one very common function here is the
michaelis-menten function and this is
typically something you see when you
have saturation
so say for example if you have a
production event
and you produce some protein
and the production of the proteins
activated by a transcription factor
and if you have something like
here you can see that if the catalyst if
c becomes towards goes towards infinity
well this rate goes towards infinity
however what you have is you always have
some kind of saturation so when you want
to produce a protein well you have
limited amount of uh for example dna
there's only one gene typically for the
uh the protein your limit amount of
ribosomes so even if you have an
infinite amount of the activator you
have a maximum rate at which you can
produce your protein
and here
are going to have a simple
self-activation model and one reason is
actually going to get back to this later
we'll do some simulation stuff where
production would go from mass wing to
producing x
and we have the def again but instead of
like before having a a constant birth
rate i'm gonna say the production of x
actually depends on activator and
activator is going to be x itself
and then i use this michelism function
which
is x divided by x plus k
and then multiply by some v some maximum
production rate
and then we can see we get this equation
we have v x divided by k plus x minus
this constant thing
now one thing this is interesting
actually we have already implemented
because this is a function where
margin occurs quite a lot so if you are
used to m m of
x v k
and then you would get this same
function
so here you have the
this function can just be intro
written like this
and then catalyst know that oh you want
the michaelis mentioned function
and in the same way there's uh the
miguel's mental function actually
special case of the so-called hill
function
and the hill function basically exponent
n to x k and x here
so we're going to have instead of having
x where x to the power of m x to the
power of n k to the power n and if set n
is equal to one we are just going to get
the michaelis-magnetic function and
again we can then just write hill
k v
x v k n
and we get this one
and currently these two are only like
functions which already implemented
but we think those are the most common
one people who want to use
and another thing you can use is
you can have time here
so the simple t
uh designates the time
uh
of the systems like
uh how long you are in the simulation
and again if you just write for example
b divided by t
so you have a birth def model but i just
say that the rate of birth is going to
be reduced
with the time of the system so as
we go very far into the simulation the
birth rate is going to be very small
and then we can see that over here
we get this b divided by t
and this is going to work perfectly fine
and one way you can do this
and this is a slightly convoluted way to
write it but this you can basically make
a birth thing with have birth
time some function here which is going
to be a step function so before time t
naught
this thing is going to be zero
and after t naught
this is going to have b b
and then you can have a simulation where
nothing happens in the beginning and
then some time t not
suddenly that birth kicks on and the
system starts happening
and one reason of writing this one here
is actually i don't recommend to use
this approach and so there's something
which called callbacks uh which people
familiar with differential equations
might be familiar with
uh and this is basically a way to
implement events
and this is a
clearer and cleaner way to do this in
addition when this is going to create a
discontinuity in the system so you're
going to have some time
where
you go from having zero rate to uh rate
b and this might also create problems
with numerical solvers so you can do
like this
but you probably don't want to do it
like this
and then
i just want to show off this thing
because one thing which is nice with
julia uh is that you can use unicode
characters in your code
uh so for example uh here we have
i never really showed you back and you
can you can do a backwards arrow so you
can do an event uh
k
x
something like this i have no idea where
you actually want to do this but this is
possible
but in principle all different arrows
can be used uh instead of so if you this
here looks nicer you can write it like
this instead of like that
and especially if you use something like
uh vs code is quite easy uh to get you
just to
that uh left right
row you can auto complete and you get
something like this
uh and i mean it depends on taste
i think in this case
using
this is probably just as good
but you can also for example use greek
letter symbols
so one thing i'm working on something
called bacterial sigma factors and all
sigma factors uh that call something
like sigma v
and if i can't use unicode characters uh
i would have to write my sigma something
like this
which works
but can actually use my
sigma v here in the model so here our
production reaction will go for nothing
and here again you can use the empty set
symbol instead of zero
uh this is quite equivalent
but it's a matter of taste and here i
can write sigma and i can even use some
superscript so here i write sigma v
and in this case i think this actually
helped me because it makes it's easier
for me to look at the model and see okay
this is sigma v
and if i show it to my experimentalist
colleague it's also like a little bit
nicer
and here for example i can write v node
using
subscript zero
and again like this doesn't matter
awfully much but
i i think it's nice that you can do
these kind of things
and yet then i have like a final thing
here
that you can bypass the law of mass
action so really the law of mass action
is what we use to calculate the rate at
which an uh
reaction occur so for example we said
that this
reaction occurred at rate p1
but for example if you have def uh def
event you're then going to have p2 times
the concentration of x and if you have
uh
for example a binding event you have two
things you're gonna have times the
concentration of both things
and i think you almost all want to have
this but say that you're in the dsl want
to disable this
and just really customize at which rate
this occur you can use this type of
arrow uh so i have like unfilled arrow
like this
and then we're gonna have i have like
different uh five different reactions we
have five different things we'll create
spaces one y one to y five
and here we can see that production rate
of y one two three four five is just
going to be p one p two three four three
five
independently of what we write here
and i think like
99 percent of the time you don't really
want to do this
but sometimes you have someone
that have like a model where it's mostly
biochemical reaction network model but
it's something strange going on
somewhere and they want to like
customize that one
and then this allows you to do that
i think if you end up using these kind
of things for all of your reactions
uh you might
maybe there's like a different modeling
package instead of catalyst you should
look at
but if you want to add some funny things
this is possible and this is just by
giving the user options to
say what i want to not want
and here like another like small thing
so say like i create a model and i
create a binding model where we have
a production degradation of two
components x and y so we produce x and y
to degrade
and then we can bind and form a single
complex xy
and then if i want to investigate my
model or this like you usually just
input binding model to whatever methods
you want whenever you simulate to
something else but if you want to have a
look
then you can do species of your model
and you get a list of the species of the
system
and you can do parameters and you get
listed parameters
and if you do reactions you get a list
of reactions
and if you want to like look into this
like a few different more fields in
reactions in order the reaction system
is in binding model here
but i think these ones are probably the
main ones you might be interested in
yeah uh and then like
at the end of most notebooks we're gonna
have like so this is the end of this
segment and i'm gonna hammer to sam but
gonna say that in the end of most of the
bigger notebooks uh they're gonna be a
set of exercises we might have some
breaks uh and this can be some like
useful thing if you want to work
yourself with
uh
so yeah
and so here if you open this notebook
input in the end you can see like here's
some quite simple exercises to do
uh
and with that uh i think i'm gonna hand
over to sam for the next section
all right uh thank you torkle um
so
i think
since we're already maybe a little
behind schedule that uh let's just keep
going and maybe we can plan a break
halfway through um i think that might be
the best way to do it
um
so
i'm gonna
share
this
and hopefully i can add it to the stream
okay cool um so what i wanted to go
through is a little bit about what's
going on under the hood um
so we just saw a really nice overview of
kind of all the power of the dsl from
torquel and how you can use it to
implement uh
type in and enter chemical reaction
networks in a bunch of different ways uh
and a bunch of different notations and
adding different functions uh for rate
laws and such to it
but what's going on under the hood when
you then take that and you call ode
problem on it to simulate it or you call
sd problem to simulate it like he showed
at the beginning um and we'll show more
about simulation right after this
section but i wanted to show you kind of
what's going on under the hood a little
bit before we then go and show you about
the simulations um so basically i wanted
to make sure everybody knows
what is the when we create an ode and
simulate an ode model with catalyst
what's the od model what's the jump
process model what's the sde model um
tell you a little bit about how it
relates to uh modeling toolkit and how
if you don't like the way we're building
chemical rate laws how you can modulate
that
with this combinatoric rate laws option
um
okay so
here uh let's look at what happens like
with an abstract just ode model that we
build via catalyst okay so here's kind
of the most general way i could write a
mass action type of reaction i have
species s1 to sl and i have m1 of s1 as
as a substrate and m2 of s2 and so on
and so forth and i make n1 of s1 and 2
of s2
this is my general reaction
um what does this actually give me when
i generate odes with catalyst okay well
if i call nu sub i the change in species
i so it's the product stoichiometry
minus the substrate stoichiometry this
is the change in the ice species due to
the reaction and what catalyst assumes
is that the ode term this reaction
generates is that stoichiometry
coefficient times the rate of the
reaction times a rate law that has this
form it's the product of the species
amounts to the substrate stoichiometries
divided by this factorial term
uh and the reason that i wanted to show
you this is to make so that everybody
could see this because sometimes when
people are doing ode modeling with
reaction networks they don't want to
have this factorial their rate already
has it built in so i'll show you in a
little bit how you could get rid of it
um so this is the term that would appear
in the ode for the elf species from this
one reaction and then you can generate
other ones analogously
and this would correspond to basically
typing in a reaction like this you know
module i put dot dots instead of typing
all the abstract terms
so that's kind of what an ode that comes
out actually is when you run this
so one question though is we're talking
about catalyst is a symbolic modeling
system that is a symbolic model for a
reaction system and it uses modeling
toolkit
for the ode systems or the jump systems
or scds how can we actually get at those
and so i wanted to kind of just show you
quickly how you could get at that
so
catalyst reaction systems that you
generate via the dsl like here
can be converted into odes or non-linear
equations or steady-state equations or
sdes or jump process systems
and these are all types of modeling
toolkit abstract systems
and so when you type this in what you're
doing is creating a symbolic reaction
system rn is a reaction system in julia
and that is a type of modeling toolkit
abstract system
[Music]
and so really one could also just
directly type in the reaction system and
we'll show you how to do that a little
later when we're doing some fancier
applications
then we need to specify of course like
we saw earlier our initial condition
mapping so this says initially i have
one x one y one z initially i set my
rate to be one
i set the time interval i want to solve
on to be zero to ten and then i create a
differential equations j dot jl ode
problem from my reaction system okay and
that's what i can now solve using
differential equations
but under the hood this is doing a lot
of work when you call ode problem it's
taking your reaction system here
and it's generating a symbolic set of
odes and then it's calling ode problem
on those in modeling toolkit and so you
can actually do that yourself if you
want more flexibility so here i'm
converting the catalyst reaction system
into an ode system by calling convert
and you see that gives us our odes
symbolically
you could have been modeling toolkit
actually just type these ods in yourself
directly
as using the symbolics.jl variables to
type them in and we'll see some examples
of that a little later how to type in
odes directly and so this is the kind of
symbolic equations that are stored in
the ode system
um
and of course here you see those
combinatorial factors that i pointed out
in the rate law
[Music]
and at that point we can kind of instead
of solving and simulating the od
creating an od problem from the reaction
network we could equivalently take this
symbolic ode system and make an ode
problem and simulate that
which is what catalyst is doing under
the hood
so first i take my mappings from symbols
to numbers for the initial condition in
the parameter and i have to put them in
a form that modeling toolkit can use and
modeling toolkit always works with
symbolics.jl
symbolic variables so i have to convert
this julia symbol
into a symbolic variable and that's what
this function here does it's just
converting them over
and then i can taking the the symbolic
ode system and the converted initial
conditions and parameters i can create
an ode problem from that
and if i go and now solve my two
different ode problems on the left i've
got the od problem coming directly from
our reaction network on the right i've
got the od problem where i took our
reaction network i converted into a
symbolic ode system and then i made an
ode problem from that and sure enough we
get the same answer with both of them
so this gives us a little insight into
what's going on under the hood we're
converting our reaction systems into
modeling toolkit symbolic ode systems
and that's a place where you can
possibly perturb the system later on if
you want to modify the odes or such um
and we'll see a little more about that
like i said when i talk about hodgkin
huxley so
okay uh so as an aside i mentioned
that our normal rate laws divide
uh in in that reaction that i had up
here
this generated this rate law this term
in the ode but i said what if you don't
want the factorial what if your rate
constant's already got that built in
which many people often have how can i
generate it well it's actually very easy
when you create an ode problem you just
pass a keyword argument called
combinatoric rate laws and you set it to
false and then that gets rid of these
combinatorial factors
if i convert to an ode system
before making an ode problem i can pass
combinatoric rate laws into that and now
my symbolic ode system also no longer
has those factorial terms appearing it
just has the stoichiometry right i'm
losing 2x 3y and gaining 4z for this
reaction
so that's a way i can disable and
slightly change the rate law depending
on how i want to interpret my rate
constants
right this is this here is what we had
previously and then this was the version
without the combinatoric rate laws
and sure enough if we solve the version
where we create an ode problem from our
from a reaction system or we solve the
version where we create it from
converting to an ode system and then
creating an ode problem again we get the
same answer okay so the punch line is
just kind of two things we can always
create things by passing our reaction
system from the dsl into the ode problem
or sd problem or we can
take it and convert it to symbolic ods
and then pass that into ode problem
and if we want to disable
these combinatoric scalings we can just
use this combinatoric rate laws argument
either to ode problem when we're
creating that from a reaction system
directly or into ode system when we're
converting our reaction system into a
symbolic system of odes
okay so so far we've talked a lot about
odes i just wanted to mention very
briefly and then i think we're then
going to show you some pictures and how
we actually do some simulations for some
different models um
what are the actual equations that we're
getting when we have sdes chemical
longivian equations or jump processes um
so if this is the reaction again
this is the ode we said catalyst makes
by default where this term here the k
times the product is the rate law of the
reaction
well this is the corresponding chemical
launch of an equation sde model that the
reaction would generate in catalyst so
this is how the elf species is impacted
by this reaction you'll notice there's a
drift term that's exactly the same as
the odes term so that's the same but
then there's a noise term where this is
a brownian motion that gets multiplied
by the square root of the rate law times
the stoichiometry um
the corresponding
net stoichiometry coefficient okay so
this is your classical chemical
longevity equation and when you make an
sde system from a reaction network or an
sd problem this is what a catalyst is
internally generating for you
if you're interested in gillespie
methods or stochastic chemical kinetics
you have
this type of equation that comes up this
is what's called the time change
representation
um and so this is a jump process where
the amount of species uh the elf species
is changing according to a unit poisson
counting process
whose time is evaluated based on the
integral of this function a
so basically here nu l is how much this
species changes when the reaction occurs
it's the net stoichiometry and y is
counting how many times the reaction
occurs so when y has the value five the
reaction has occurred five times and you
change sl by five times the amount the
reaction changes it
and what sets the rate or the intensity
or the transition rate of our jump
process is this what's called the
propensity function
a of s1 to sl
and what catalyst assumes is that your
propensity function has the following
form
it's k times the product of s i s i
minus 1 down to s i minus the substrate
coefficient
plus 1 over m i factorial
so maybe it's worth typing in so for
example if you had 2a goes to zero
i'll just write this as a comment then
what you would get is something like
uh for that rate law you would have k
times a times a minus one
over two
that's what the rate law the probability
per time that the reaction would occur
in catalyst would be for the jump
process and just like
sometimes you don't want these
factorials and you use this combinatoric
rate law to get rid of them for odes you
can pass the same argument when you're
creating sd problems from a reaction
system or an sd system from a reaction
system to get rid of the factorial terms
here if you don't want them
so just to kind of show you that
here's how we would create an sde
problem for the chemical logic and
equation directly from our reaction
network
and then you can pass in the
combinatoric rate laws if it's true that
would keep those factorial terms here's
how we convert it to a symbolic modeling
toolkit sd system and then we create an
sd problem we can solve from that
and then here's how we do a jump process
model
if we want to go directly from the
reaction system we create a discrete
problem to tell differential equations
dot jl that our process is evolving in
jumps it's not changing continuously in
time
and then we say that the type of
discrete jump problem we have a type of
discrete problem we have is a jump
problem
um and here we pass in this extra
argument to tell it how do we want to
actually choose what reaction occurs in
the time they occur and we'll talk more
about that later but this for those of
you have seen these models before this
is what's called gillespie's direct
method so this is saying use golesby's
direct method to sample which reaction
occurs and what time the reaction occurs
at
but a completely equivalent way to do
that would be to convert our reaction
system into a modeling toolkit symbolic
jump system and then make a discrete
problem from that and a junk problem
from that
so there's always this workflow option
of going directly from the reaction
system or going uh via
uh the model the symbolic mathematical
model that you want to use um and we'll
exploit that in some of the applications
that we're going to show in the second
part of the the tutorial the kind of
second half of the tutorial
um and i think that that was everything
i had for this part so i think now
torkle is going to take over and tell us
a little bit actually show us some
examples of actually doing some
simulations since we've kind of shown
you a lot maybe abstract it's time to
start showing you some actual using
catalyst
and you're a mood you're muted right now
torkel
being muted seems inconvenient
okay
uh hopefully everything should be in
place now okay
so so this section is really like
simulating catalyst models
and i will go through like a few
different like how you do various types
of simulation things for example if you
want to do like monte carlo simulations
and just like the basic syntax
and i think this is all gonna use uh
so i said already
you have differential equations.jl uh
this package which probably is one of
the most well known julia packages but
if you're here and not a julia person i
should just say like
this is the tool we use for simulations
uh
and
they're probably going to be a few
people in audience who are very well
familiar we have to use that package and
you're going to see a lot of things
you're familiar with
so first we're going to just start with
again declaring the model
and here like i hinted a little bit
before
we're going to have this positive
feedback model
and this has some nice properties
so we can see some cool thing in
simulations
and here basically we have a single
species x which gets produced and which
get degraded
we have linear degradation
so just disappear
and then we have
the production it's a hill function of x
and that means that the rate of x
production
is going to increase the more x we have
so i have this positive feedback that if
we get increased production in x well
we're going to have more x if we're more
x the rate of x production increase uh
and then that kind of goes on
uh
and we have a couple of parameters we're
not going to pay very much note to it
but i have this parameter i which stands
for input
and i kind of like here we have the
activating term in the hill function
which is x and i
and the beginning is going to say is one
server constant input but they're going
to do some things for this one later and
so i'm just going to flag that already
now
okay but now we use catalyst so i've
created a positive feedback model
and now we're just gonna simulate it
and so the first thing i've already
showed this before
uh you're an ordinary differential
equation uh simulation
and first we declare our initial
condition and here we have a vector in
the vector we're going to list all or
species
and we're just going to use this power
weight like say that
the initial conditional species x is
going to be 5.0
okay here we're only one species there's
only one here
next time span and
typically you're going to start from
zero but you could start from
some other time point
sometimes i do simulations where
something is going to happen and then
maybe i say like this activation this
happening event still happens at time
zero but i do my simulation from an
early point time point so you could
actually have like a simulation that
starts at time -10
and then it goes on for 100 time units
and then i'm going to set my parameter
values and i use the same notation here
for the initial condition i list my
parameters in a vector and for each of
them i say which value they have
and then okay
now we have everything i need to know
for my model from simulation i have a
model an initial condition how long i
simulate it my parameter values
uh and then i just call this solve
command on my ordinary differential
equation uh
problem i get a solution object and i
plot the object
and here i can see so we see that we're
starting the issue notation from five x
molecules or a concentration of five and
then with time we go to this steady
state slightly over concentration 11.
if we look at the soul command
previously this is my first presentation
i only had a single
uh here ordinary differential equation
problem but here i actually give this
rules and brock 23 argument
and this designate which numerical soul
we use
so if you don't set any one
differential equations we'll just auto
pick one which they think is good uh but
you can also set which one to introduce
yourself and for small simple models uh
i always want this ruse and book 23
solver is very good
but if you really want performance like
there are people that know very very
well which server to use and if you go
to different equation you can see
there's tons and tons of different
servers
and here just saying that
if you want to like change the
properties this plot command there's
tons and tons of options to use for
example here i can set my
the x label to time y label
concentration here
i really like to have this frame style
box we have a box around the plot
instead of just having two axises
lv stands for line width so i can make
this line thicker
here label it will just nothing i can
remove this label
uh and if you go to like the plots
package so it's just
plots dot jl and then check attributes
and you can find tons of these options
so i'm not going to discuss that any
further but it's very much possible
and then again if we want to use these
chemical login equations to make a
stochastic differential equation
simulation
again i'm just going to say i create an
sd problem instead of an od problem
and then
again i call the solve command
for stochastic differential equations i
have to use different set of solvers uh
quite often i just use this implicit am
which stands for implicit oil mariama
solver to solve my stds stuff
and then again use the plot command but
the really the only difference here i
said i want an sd problem
and then
catalyst will say okay we're going to
use the cut chemical laundry in a pre
approximation
implementation of those assam showed
previously
uh and here i'm just gonna show like the
first additional feature
uh
so say that i kind of want to see like
how noise affect the simulation and i
see here we get this like nice
transition
and here we see that the noise kind of
like
the amount of noise uh you can't really
see how like we approach the new steady
state
so maybe i want to tune the amount of
noise in the system
and here i want i'm gonna declare a new
model uh positive feedback noise scaling
and the only difference is gonna add an
additional parameter here at that
and this is because i want to tune the
amount of noise or tight amount of noise
to this at a parameter
okay so what i do then of course i have
an additional parameter uh at i want to
have to set this to value gonna set 0.1
and then when i create my sd problem i
just can add additional option argument
noise scaling is equal to
and then i use this thing here which is
modeling tool cap toolkit
type notation
uh
and i won't really go into data much
here but
just if you're interested in scaling
noise i would just copy something like
this in the beginning and then maybe
learn what this actually mean
but here i said i declare a parameter at
that which is the same one here
and then i solve it and plot it and then
we see we got a lot less noise than we
got here
and here you just linearly scale uh
the
noise term which sam shows
shown before but it's at the parameter
which is 0.1
i'm not saying that this is always a
good idea uh
the like
amount of noise for these reactions
should be for at is equal to one but
there might be situation where it's
convenient to like see what happens i
haven't what i often see if i have
someone else have implemented an od
model
i want to see what happens what to have
a noise here and if i directly use the
chemical launch of an equation i just
get a noisy mess
something like that
and then i say okay i'm just gonna like
add a little bit noise and then slowly
scale up the noise and see what happens
as i approach at is equal to one
and then you can use this noise scaling
option
and
next
what happens if i use a lot of noise and
say a noise hair set is equal to 6.0
and we see we get this quite immense
fluctuations and this is a rather
artificial example
but i just want to show that
if i run this again
yeah so sometimes i might get this arrow
where i get blah blah blah blah blah
blah
mother specification the solution is
unstable and sometimes what happens is
that because
differential equations automatically use
uh automat
adaptive time stepping and if you get a
lot of things happen really fast it
might think the solution like the is
unstable and you're gonna hold it before
you reach the final time and here we can
see we'll reach
about nine time units
and one way around this uh is that you
can actually disable noise uh disable
adaptive
time stepping so here i'm gonna use the
same thing click parameter create an sd
problem and solve it
but then to the solution i'm going to
add an argument adaptive is equal to
false so i'm going to turn off the
adaptive type stepping
and then set dt is equal to this
and then i'm just going to take a fixed
time steps and just make time step every
0.001
and then we see we can actually like
solve this without problem
and then again now we see like
if you use this and it's a very small dt
so here we're going to save every 0.001
time unit so in total we're going to
save 100 times 0.01 we might get a very
dense solution
and one additional argument that might
be useful here is to have this save at
which means that i'm just going to use
dt is equal to 0.01 but i'm not going to
save it at every time uh i returned
thousand time unit i'm just going to
save it every 10th time unit
because i don't need to save that much
in the cloaks up memory
and so really this combination of
arguments can be good
if you have this problem
now if i actually were to look at this
solution we can see we had so much noise
that we quite often here have negative
concentration of course we can't have
negative species concentration x
so something bad is going on here
and one way you can make some kind of
pullback i'm not showing this today but
there are ways to force you to be in a
positive domain
but quite often i say that if you are
encountering that you go into the
negative domain
uh you probably should not use
an sd problem so then for a very high
noise or very low species concentration
uh the assumptions of the chemical
engineering equations we use to
implement uh sd equations breakdown
and then you should use gillespie's
approach
to make this jump
simulations which sam will go into more
detail later on
and this is like a thing like yeah you
can solve it here but if you have this
negative species concentration you
probably should use this approach
instead
uh
and
here as i mentioned callbacks earlier
when i discuss time
so quite often what i have i look at
biochemical system we have some input
and kind of like you have a system which
is not steady state not much happen and
then you add something and then the
system activate
uh
and there
you want to like implement at a certain
time something happens so some kind of
event
and if you go to differential equations
uh
and search for call
callback callbacks
and this is
basically events are handled and a lot
of different options
and certainly already implemented and
i'm just going to here show a very
simple callback
so this is going to be a so-called
preset time callback
which
say at some time point something happens
and i create this activation callback in
this case by calling preset time or two
argument the first is the time points
when this happens
and here i'm going to say a time point
20 something happened and this effect
function
was gonna
change the state of the simulator and
this takes one argument an integrator
and agreement if you search for
integrator
dfaq you can find
exactly how this object looks like
and here i'm just going to very simply
say that you take the integrator
you take set p field
p
and you take the first argument uh here
this is the first parameter
and the first parameter we can see
when to current model is going to be
this i
uh
i'm going to take the first one and i'm
going to set this equal to three
and then okay i want to simulate i set
my parameters it's gonna be the same
before but this input argument is gonna
be zero
and
i'm gonna
make my sd problem briefly no ignore
this deep copy thing i will explain this
later on what this is important
and then here i set this optional
argument
callback x equal to activation
cb
and here actually have these arguments
and adaptive
i think it might just be a remainder
from one use it but anyway
and this is gonna say this here and we
can see that before time 20
the solution can uh uh are around this
10
which is about similar at uh as it was
before
uh so here it's like 10 15.
but then we can see around time 20
something happens
when this callback kicks in and increase
the input argument free and we see that
concentrations start rising and when
they reach like a final concentration of
x around 100
and then we can say probably like this
system had two different steady states
we have one steady state here for low
concentration x and one for high
concentration x and here switching this
input
moves us into this high state
and this you can use using these
callbacks
now
we see here that this is a very noisy
thing
and often what you have if you simulate
something with noise you want to make
several simulations to like see
what different outcomes can we get so
here for example you want to make monte
carlo simulation
and here i've simulated the same system
15 times
and of course one way to do this is that
you just simulate run this one time you
run it a total of 15 times saves all of
the solutions and plot them together
but there's an easy way to do it
and that's creating an ensemble problem
so uh
the start is going to be very similar i
have the same parameters
uh i create the same sd problem
and then i want to create an ensemble
problem where basically take my sd
problem
and pass that to solve and say like i
want to solve this several times
and then you need an additional you need
something you have something called a
problem function
and this problem function
is going to take your problem
and i
is going to say
so basically no i'm going to take from
this end so when i create my sample
solution i'm going to solve my ensembl
problem and i'm just gonna use uh select
which sd solo i want to use i'm gonna
give it the callback again so i want to
use the same callback but i'm gonna give
this tractor is 15 which basically say
like i want to solve my sd problems 15
times
and i'm going to plot the solution and
here we've got the 15 tractors
now
this problem function
is not going to do much now it basically
take gonna take your problem
and a usd problem and apply this
function to the problem at the beginning
of the simulation
and this is important that say for
example if you want to do an ensemble
solution
but
say that you want to simulate an od
problem for 15 different initial
conditions
uh
and then you actually like you not want
to solve the same
problem in every iteration
so here i solve a stochastic problem
want to uh
solve the same problem every time so the
problem function is just going to return
the original problem
uh that's the problem but you have this
i
which is iteration so it's going to
go between 1 and 15 and then repeat is
just going to be these 15 things which
is the total number of repeats
and and then you might want to like
modify your problem here
but if you want to just make an sd
monte carlo where i solve the same
stochastic problem several times
this problem function is just going to
be this trivial problem function of this
is equal to problem
and there's like a small thing we much
need to watch out for here and then if
you see
i only add the input at time 20
and you see like for example this blue
simulation looks like previously but for
some of these simulations here we see
that we actually start to activate
before 20 before the callback kick in
and there's a reason for this
and this is slightly technical but i
want to like say this because
this can cause some problems with people
and what's going to happen here is that
i sold my problem the first time
so i sold my sd problem
in my first iteration
and then the callback cx in a time 20
here
and modify the parameter i to become
free
and then
i solve it again for the same sd problem
using the same parameter set but in the
second simulation it's just going to use
the same parameter set which was
modified
by the callback
so this like the
remaining 14 times i solve this problem
actually i'm going to start with i is
equal to three
and so actually what i have to do here
is to make some modification
and here actually i'm going to use this
problem function
so going to say in the beginning of
every monte carlo simulation i'm going
to take my problem
and i'm going to call this remake
function which basically is a way to
modify an differential equation problem
and again i say p is equal to deep copy
so this is just a copy of
the original parameter set
and this gonna say like in the beginning
of every simulation i'm gonna take my
problem and modify it uh by setting this
parameter set
and this and search and we can see here
that uh when i modify the parameter set
i only modified for this iteration of
the monte carlo simulation not all of
them and here we can see all 15
simulation we go to 10.20 and then they
activate nicely
okay
and this is pretty much more the color
simulations uh but there's going to show
up some simple thing so one thing i like
to do when i plot a lot of these
simulations like the plot gets quite
messy you can use this line alpha
argument to the plot thing which kind of
like fades the line so if this is zero
uh it's going to be all transparent but
making the slightly more transparent i
think makes the plot nicer
and you can also use this indexes
argument if you only want to plot a
subset so if your index one to five and
here i will plot the first five
simulations
and i think i actually missed this
but one important thing here
is that
this
ensemble thing can automatically
parallelize your solutions
so if you shake it up this actually if
you do an
ensemble solution
there's actually an additional argument
here
uh
which is an ensemble solver
uh and
you for example have this solver which
says that oh i want to solve this but i
automatically want to parallelize over
the threads to my computer
um or i can do ensemble
serial which is naively going to solve
one and then the next without any kind
of parallelization
and actually this threads is the
automatic
selection
so this
in addition to be a nice way to just
bundle all of the simulations
automatically allows you to parallelize
your
solution and i'm just gonna show up some
like
very small features
uh so my previous uh i only have a
simple single uh
state let's say that i have a two-state
model server state x and one state x2
and then i make this simulation i can
see these two here
but then if i use the vars
argument
then i will only display the second
variable so then only stay x2 so say if
you have a large model with maybe like
100 species you probably don't want to
sew all of your species and then you can
use this to say that it's actually only
this one or these few number of species
which i want to show the concentration
of
and then of course
if you want to access uh and do some
like statistics or want mean
concentration
or like find peaks or something you can
always uh access for example the
solution object sol dot u returns a
vector
with the concentration of all the
species in every state of the system
and solder t returns all of the time
points
uh and here's like another thing which i
need thing because we have this modeling
toolkit is that
if i create this model here i'm going to
use a browse later okay we're very
familiar with how to make an od
simulation
uh
but uh
if i use this
jack is equal to true argument
then i automatically compute the
jacobian
of the system
so then i here i'm not going to use
jacobian but here i can compute jacobian
for this system
and use that to hide the solution
and if it is dispatch is equal to true
thing
then i compute jacobian also make it
sparse
and this small example doesn't really
matter but i just want to show this
thing here
so here we have big model bcr
and i sold it for various simulation
length
and here i used didn't use jacobian if i
say i want to compute jacobian we see
that we get a quicker solution and i've
also say i want to be sparse
i get even quicker and here we say get
over one order of magnitude speed up by
using a
jacobian as opposed to using this case
here so this is kind of like
considerations you want to you think
about that if you have a very big model
uh there are ways to really speed up
your solution if you need space speed
and this is one way we can do it
yeah and
again here's going to be exercise if you
wanted to it at the end just like do
some sd simulations
uh but yeah
this is really the
simulation part of the presentation uh
done
uh do you think uh should we maybe take
a five minute break and then i'll come
back and talk about jump process
simulations uh and then we'll go into
kind of some higher level applications
of everything i think yes yes i i think
this having the break now is good so
maybe we'll take a five minute break
everybody and then we will resume in
five minutes and i'll put a slide up
just so everyone on the stream can see
that
so yes
all right folks welcome back um let me
get my sharing set up
okay
so we just saw from uh torkel very
nicely
how we can
some considerations when we're trying to
simulate the ode or sd models that we've
converted from catalyst and like he said
and we probably should have said much
clearer up front
we're using differential equations.jl to
do our ode our sd and our jump process
simulations so specifically we're using
ordinary difficulty.jl stochastic
difficult.jl what i'm going to tell you
about now is how we can simulate jump
processes using jump processes.jl
so we'll see some catalyst models and i
want to tell you a little bit about some
considerations that come up in questions
i've seen people get hung up on when
trying to simulate jump process models
from catalyst or even directly with
jumpprocesses.jl
um
so in particular i'll tell you some
considerations about performance tuning
so some of the different solvers you can
use how you can play or how you can
reduce memory use by the solvers because
that can
very easily get quite big
and then i'll show you how you can use
callbacks because using callbacks with
the jump processes is slightly more work
you have to be a little more aware of
what's going on than if you're trying to
use callbacks with the normal
differential equation solvers
so as kind of my illustrative example
i'm going to work with a model of what's
called a toggle switch so this is two
genes
gene one makes mrna at some rate the
mrna can degrade gene two makes mrna2 at
some rate which can degrade each of the
mrnas make their respective proteins the
proteins can degrade and those proteins
can feed back and slow down the mrnas
production so this says that notice that
these rates that mrna is getting made
here as the amount of p2 goes to
infinity the rate that m1 gets made gets
smaller and smaller and the same for m2
so these are repressive hell functions
and so basically gene one's protein
inhibits gene two gene tunes protein
inhibits gene one
um
and this is a a little dsl based model
for it that you can cook up and if you
simulate that you see a figure that
looks like this on a short time scale um
and you can see here the jump process
nature nature where the amount of say
here m2 is constant and then finally
transcription occurs and you get a new
one and finally transcription occurs and
it gets a new one so you see these kind
of long piecewise constant curves that
represent the amount the number of mrnas
and proteins at a given time and the
code for simulating that is right here
we've kind of gone through this before
but just to remind you we create
mappings from the symbols for each
parameter or var or each species to the
parameters value and the um the species
initial value and notice i'm using
integers for the species because this is
an exact jump process simulation where i
want to know the number of mrna and the
number of proteins so i can use integers
instead of floating point numbers for
that
i create a discrete problem like we've
seen a few times from our toggle switch
i create a jump problem from that and
again i'm picking gillespie's direct
method as the way that i'm going to
sample which reaction occurs next and
which time it occurs at and in
differential of reasons sorry in jump
processes.jl
we called this an aggregator so an
aggregator is in charge of figuring out
which reaction should i execute and when
should i execute it
but in addition to giving an aggregator
when i call solve i have to give a time
stepper that reads what's the next
reaction what's the next time and
updates the solution uh saves the new
solution state updates the current time
in the system and that's what ssa
stepper does um so it's a special time
stepping algorithm specifically for
these kinds of gillespie method problems
or stochastic chemical kinetics problems
that's optimized to be fast for them
and so here's just an example of doing
that and what you can see comes out of
it
and so let's start talking a little bit
about optimizing that um so
if you look at this graph
we're really saving every single jump of
the process and in fact every time this
guy jumps we have to save two numbers it
saves the state before the reaction
occurs and so it jumps down and then the
state after
and so you can imagine if you have a lot
of transitions a lot of reactions you
start saving an enormous amount of
points and very quickly
you're going to destroy your memory
especially if you're trying to use an
ensemble problem to run hundreds of
thousands of simulations and collect
statistics like torquel was showing
before
so what we can do to get around that is
of course don't save the solution at
every single reaction event just save it
periodically at some fixed times um and
so i wanted to just show you how to do
that because there's a little bit more
one needs to do when you have a jump
problem to do that
the first thing you need to do and
here's kind of the code showing it is
when you create your jump problem you
need to set the save positions keyword
argument to false false okay so what
this says is don't save the state of my
system right before the reaction
occurred and don't save the state right
after it occurred right after you jumped
so by doing that you'll no longer have a
curve that tells you exactly the
solution at every point in time but you
won't be saving every single reaction
event the state of the system which uses
up much less memory
then i couple that within the solve
command telling the solver to only save
every 10 seconds or every 10 time units
and putting those two together i save
much less data and that allows me in
this case to simulate my system up to
time a hundred thousand time units which
for this toggle switch is kind of cool
because what we see is we get this
switching where sometimes the system is
in the state where there's a lot of p1
and only a little bit of p2 but then the
stochastic fluctuations kick me
sometimes into a state where i get a lot
of p2 and a little p1 and it goes back
and forth flipping back and forth and
just to show you
if i run this
it should be pretty quick if i run this
when i'm not streaming it's
instantaneous if i run it while i'm
streaming it takes five seconds um but
as you can see
we run it and pretty quickly we get a
new solution curve and we see the flip
even though i'm running out to a hundred
thousand seconds and i do promise you it
is a lot quicker than it appeared there
the streaming is slowing my computer
down um
so that's one way to control and speed
up your simulations is make sure you're
only saving at the times you need to
save and make sure you use this save
positions keyword so that it's not
saving every single time a reaction
occurs when you're simulating your jump
process
um
now i was going to tell you a bit about
what's in a modeling toolkit jump system
but maybe i'll just very very briefly
overview it because i want to save a
little time um
basically
when you turn a catalyst reaction model
into a gillespie method model into a
modeling toolkit jump system there's a
decision that has to get made so
differential equations.jl and jump
processes can encode three different
types of jump processes
there's what's called variable rate
jumps which are very general and they
work for pretty much any type of rate
function and state change you want but
they're kind of slow to simulate
there's what's called constant rate
jumps which have some limitations on
them but are much faster to simulate and
then there's an even faster special case
called mass action jumps
where if we know our reaction is just a
regular mass action reaction with a
special rate constant we can put it in
even more optimized form
and so jump processes.jl its solvers
work
with these various
types of jumps and the more you can get
your system as mass action jumps the
faster your simulations will generally
go and the cool thing about catalyst is
if you want to use jump processes.jl
directly by hand you have to go and say
okay is this jump a variable rate jump
for example if you had a rate constant k
of t that wasn't time that was time
dependent then you would need to make it
a variable rate jump um
but catalyst will automatically bin
things into the optimal jump type for
you so you never have to think about
that you just let catalyst handle all of
that
and there's a lot more detail if you
want to understand what's going on under
the hood in terms of the types of jumps
on jump processes.jl but i think i'm
going to leave it at that just for the
purposes of this workshop
and instead what i want to tell you a
bit about is what are some of the
simulation algorithms that are available
for jump processes
and there's basically eight of them that
we've got available so we haven't quite
matched uh what chris has developed for
ordinary diff eq where there's like 200
methods
but we've got eight of them and they
offer kind of a trade-off between their
performance and the types of systems
that they're fastest on as i'll show you
in a minute
so from catalyst when you make your jump
system and your jump problem you can use
any of these some of these require
things called dependency graphs that say
when a given reaction occurs it will
change these species
which other reactions have rate walls
depending on those species because we
need to calculate recalculate their rate
laws after the change and so there's
these things called dependency graphs
that if you've ever looked at these
stochastic simulation algorithms before
you might have seen and one typically
has to construct them to use the more
optimized algorithms luckily for us
catalyst and modeling toolkit does all
of that for us and so we can just use
any of them right out of the box we
don't have to do any extra building
and there's eight of them there's
gillespie's direct method which is kind
of the standard jump process simulation
algorithm and is really good for small
systems of three four reactions maybe
even ten
there's the first reaction method the
next reaction method the sorting direct
method
this rejection direct method
um the composition rejection direct
method and these two rejection ssa
methods
and these ones i put in italics are ones
that generally are among the best
performing ones for given applications
which is kind of what i wanted to show
you a bit about
so usually you want to pick try some
subset of these and one of them will
probably be the fastest for your given
reaction system
um
so i wanted to just show you a few
examples of different reaction systems
and the performance these different
solvers come out to show you how it can
vary so i'm using here examples coming
from the difficult problem library um so
you can you can load the difficulty
problem library to load these examples
yourself
um
and the first one that i wanted to look
at is just a very simple gene
so this is a catalyst model for a gene
network that's in the problem library so
i haven't typed it out i'm just loading
it in
this is a gene that makes mrna the mrna
makes protein the protein in mrna can
degrade and the the gene can bind to a
protein or a protein can bind to the
gene and turn it off put it into this
repressed or turned off state okay so
it's a very simple system it's got one
two five species uh and see it's got six
reactions and if i simulate it and kind
of look at the median run time across
all of all those different methods i
showed you uh and here we're looking at
the time relative to direct then we see
that the fastest method is the sorting
direct method which is maybe you know 80
70 80 85 percent uh
this uh
the run time of direct so it's a bit
faster
and the rest of the methods are slower
than direct so this is a small system
and that jerkel sb's direct method is
the fastest
is about the fastest though you'd get a
little bit of a performance boost with
the sorting direct method
if we go to a slightly more complicated
system
so here now we've got a network
that's got i don't know maybe about 20
reactions and maybe about 10 species
that we took out of this paper by gupta
and mendez and this is just the network
that's modeling um
a protein that can be phosphorylated
have different phosphorylation states
and undergo enzymatic reactions in those
states
so it has a lot of structure it's what's
called the multi-state model of that
paper
and if we go and we take that model and
now we load it in and then we run these
different solvers on it we see kind of a
different set of benchmarking results so
again sorting direct is one of the
fastest but this rssa this rejection ssa
method is actually a bit faster um
and so it actually does a bit better and
they're both a decent amount faster than
regular direct right they're i don't
know what is this 40 faster 30 faster
which for a given simulation that only
takes you know a tenth of a second maybe
you don't think that's a big deal but if
you want to collect statistics and run a
hundred thousand simulations that starts
adding up and so using these faster
solvers can make your life a lot nicer
and better um by giving you more speed
and reducing the time you're sitting and
staring at the computer
and this just to make a big jump now
uh torquel mentioned this b-cell
receptor signaling pathway model
which has about a thousand species and
24 000 reactions so it's a very big
model um
and we can load it in using uh the
reaction network importers package uh
this is a cyaml package that can load
bionetgen exported files into catalyst
so it's a way to get
models that are developed in another
simulator into catalyst and if you go
and take a look at that package there's
some examples showing how to use it um
we can kind of look at how well the
various catalyst methods do compared to
bionet gen itself which uses this
sorting direct method and we see the
following kind of results um so again
this is simulation run time in
milliseconds i believe and then this is
the final physical time that we ran the
model out to so we ran it out to 10 to
the fourth seconds or 10 to the fifth
seconds of model time
and we see that the catalyst rejection
ssa with composition rejection
simulation is by far faster than these
other methods in fact it's almost two
orders of magnitude faster than the next
fastest catalyst method
in quite a few orders of magnitude
faster than bionetgen's method which is
sorting direct
and so
i just wanted to show you these to kind
of give you the flavor that very often
when people make these jump process
gillespie models uh they just
automatically use the direct method it's
the simplest it's it's it's definitely
you know if you have a very very small
system it's about the fastest but as
soon as your systems start getting
bigger and bitter bigger there's some
other methods we've got in there that
are very well optimized and can
potentially give you much faster jump
process simulations
and the kind of basic advice just to
kind of scroll back up
would generally be for a very very small
system
use gillespie's direct method if you
have a system with maybe 10 to 20
reactions very often sorting direct will
be the fastest and if you start getting
a big system with hundreds or thousands
of reactions usually the rejection ssa
or the rejection ssa with composition
rejection are the fastest
if you actually have a spatial structure
so you want to build a model where you
have not only reactions between things
but say reactions that correspond to
hopping between lattice sites or that
correspond to something
moving between cells and you have a lot
of cells you're having things transfer
between that kind of structure can often
do good with the direct the composition
rejection direct method so sometimes
that method can actually give you the
best performance um so these ones i've
highlighted are kind of generally i
would recommend if you're ever trying to
simulate stochastic
jump process models via catalyst you
should play around with a few of these
methods especially if you have at least
10 or more reactions because you may
find much better performance with one of
these other ones
okay so the other thing i wanted to tell
you about jump process simulations is
how we can add events into them
so we saw how to do that from torquel in
the sde case and i just wanted to show
you the analogous thing for jump
processes um because there's some
there's some other there's one other
consideration that may come up um so the
first thing is that when you use this
ssa stepper to simulate a jump process
algorithm we only support what in
differential equations.jl are called
discrete events not continuous events um
and that's because we we the stepper
basically assumes the system is constant
between
reaction events or constant between the
events that could occur so we can't have
anything that evolves continuously with
ssa's stepper
so the way discrete events work as we
saw earlier is you give a condition and
that condition is checked at the end of
every jump of the system for whether
it's true and when it is true it gets
executed
and that condition can be used to change
the state of the system or change
parameters or terminate a simulation
and so what i want to show you is a
couple different ways to do this
so here let's go back to the model i
showed you a few slides ago of a gene
that gets repressed um and let's try to
make a discrete callback to stop our
simulation the first time our gene gets
gets repressed gets turned off and to
save that exit time so we're going to
try to do what's called an exit time
problem or a first passage time problem
to calculate the first time that our
gene transitions from being available to
transcribe to being repressed
and so here's a very simple code for
that
i set up my system my negative uh gene
expression model so that initially the
gene is on i'll call that state one
initially there's no the gna is not
repressed i have no protein and i have
no mrna initially
i convert it into a jump system because
i'm going to simulate it as a jump
process
and then i want to be able to
figure out um
which component of the solution vector
corresponds to the repressed state so
that i can test when i enter the
repressed state so the way i'm going to
do that is i'm going to take my jump
system and i'm going to unpack from it
the symbolic variables that modeling
toolkit stores that correspond to the
dnase the state that you're in the dna
the dna is unbound the gene is unbound
and the state that it's repressed so
these are symbolic variables um that are
used by modeling toolkit that represent
the repressed state and the unrepressed
state and then what i can do is
calculate all the states of my system
which will just be dna p dna r and
mrna
i can find which of those states is
equal to dnar in the state vector
and that will tell me in my solution
vector the index of that species okay
and now i'm ready to make my callback so
first they make a condition so here this
is the current solution this is the
taunt current time this is the
differential equations.jl integrator
object that handles that stores the
current state of the system along with
the current the past history and all the
other information
and then i'm going to pass into it the
index of the species that i want to
change i want to check for which is the
repressed the index of the dna being in
the repressed state of that state and
then i just say when my solution at that
index is 1 that's my condition
to activate my callback
and what do i do at that time well i'm
going to save the time to save the
values of the state
and then i'm going to terminate my
simulation so i'm going to tell it as
soon as this condition is won save the
state and terminate it okay
i create a discrete callback based on
that
and then i create my normal problem just
like i would normally do
here
um
so this is the uh
this is just creating the discrete
problem from the jump system passing i
don't need to pass in any initial
conditions because i set default values
if you set default values in this way
they're already attached to your system
so you don't need to pass an initial
condition
i give a time span vector and i pass in
my reaction rates which are part of the
problem that we loaded from the problem
library i'm just going to simulate it
with the direct method and so i pass
back my jump problem and my callback
and then i can call solve so i call
solve with the problem i just created
here's my problem here's my callback
i use the ssa stepper i don't save the
value at the final time because my
callback is already saving that for me
so if i saved it here i'd be saving it a
bunch of times
so i don't need to save the last value
and then i pass in my callback
and then if i run my simulation we see
the following let me run another just to
update it
and so you see here blue is the state
where the gene is available and
transcribing
and i'm making mrna and then the first
time that my gene gets repressed when
the purple jumps up to one and the blue
you can't see it jumps down to zero
that's when my simulation stops okay
and so the from that the final time in
my solution object will correspond to
the exit time that i first entered the
repressed state so i can write a little
function to save a whole bunch of exit
times if case i want to calculate their
statistics and that's what i did here
so i make a vect i say if i want to
calculate n exit times i make a vector
of length n
i loop through that vector i solve my
system
and i take out the final time in the
solution object so sol dot t is the
solution vector as torkel showed us
earlier and i just pull out the final
time in it and i save that
and that gives me back all the exit
times over in this case a hundred
thousand simulations
so i get a giant vector of all my
hundred thousand simulation uh exit
times from running the simulation a
bunch
uh i could also have used a ensemble
problem to do this as torkel showed us
um but i thought it was easier to just
make a little function of my own in the
loop
and then i can plot a histogram and
estimate the pdf of the exit time and we
see the following and so in that kind of
way we can kind of do a nice calculation
and look at the probability density
function for how long it takes my system
to first become repressed
and so a callback is a very nice way to
kind of run your system and stop it when
a first passage time problem for a first
passage time problem
okay so that was the first kind of
callback i wanted to show you one other
example of a callback which is a very
very simple drug treatment model um so
let's suppose i have a bunch of say
cancer cells
and my cancer cells are produced at rate
b and they die at rate d but they're not
dying as fast as i'd like
so what i'm going to do is i want to
give a treatment and what my treatment
is going to do is my treatment is going
to reduce the birth rate so every time i
give a treatment i'm going to take the
birth rate b and cut it in half reduce
it by 50
and i'll show you the code for that in a
minute and i'm going to give five
treatments and we'll see what happens
now the main reason i'm showing you this
is that when we modify in a callback our
solution u
or a parameter value we have to make
sure to call reset aggregated jumps what
that does is that tells gillespie's
direct method and jump processes hey we
changed the parameter or we changed the
solution you need to recalculate the
time the next jump occurs and the next
rate occurs because we change some of
the properties of the system if you
don't do that you won't get correct
results
so here's what the basic code looks like
here's my birth death system i convert
it to a jump system
i want to change the parameter b
the birth rate so i unpack that symbolic
variable from the jump system
and then i search through the parameter
vector of the system to figure out the
index of the symbolic rate uh
b inside the parameter vector that's
what b index tells me
i set up my initial conditions like
normal again converting them from the
kind of catalyst way of using symbols
into the modeling toolkit way of using
symbolic variables via the synmap to var
map function and now i'm ready to make
my callback so i'm going to use like
torquel showed earlier what's called the
preset time callback so i'll set it up
so that i treat my i give a treatment at
time 4 times 6 times 8 times 10 times
12. i just make a vector of those
treatment times
and then i make a function for how i
want to modify the state when treatment
occurs and all i do there is when i give
a treatment
i set the parameter vector that's stored
in the integrator
i evaluate it at the index of the birth
parameter and i cut it in half i
multiply it by 0.5 and then this is the
key thing i need to remember to do i
tell the integrator to reset the
aggregator the reset the jump process
solver to make sure it knows that i've
changed a parameter okay
i can take my treatment times and my
effect function that modifies the
parameter and make a preset time
callback i create a discrete problem and
a jump problem one of them i'll pass the
call back in one i won't so this will
have no treatment this will have
treatment
and then i just run my simulation
using again gillespie's direct method
and i plot it and we end up getting
these two figures up here with no
treatment we kind of go to a steady
state and fluctuate around and with
treatment at those little orange dots
the parameter that's the birth rate of
the cancer cells gets cut in half and
suddenly we see that the amount of
cancer cells goes down because they're
dying and they're not getting
put back into the system at the same
rate
so that's kind of a very simple example
but it highlights one caveat or gotcha
to be aware of if you want to use uh
these callbacks or events with jump
simulations is to make sure if you're
changing uh the solution value or you're
changing a parameter value in your in
your callback that you call reset
aggregated jumps
okay and i think that was everything
that i wanted to say on this one
um
[Music]
so let me see
so i think uh
[Music]
i'm gonna go on now unless unless any
questions have come up it doesn't look
like it though
um
this is
uh uh what i wanted to show kind of what
we wanted to talk a little bit about
next is some of the symbolic modeling
capabilities so we wanted to show you
maybe some more advanced applications
that we can use
um
for
um building chemical reaction models in
various ways
so in particular how you can build
bursty reactions where the amount of
proteins that get produced are random
so that'll be parametric stoichiometry
how you can build networks symbolically
and programmatically which can let you
build like chains of cells that you hook
together um or chains of genes that you
hook together
[Music]
and a little bit about how you can add
in constraints like odes or or or
algebraic equations to couple into your
reaction network model which i'll
illustrate with the classical
hodgkin-huxley equation
for simulating neuronal dynamics
okay so so far everything we've been
doing is via the the domain specific
language uh for catalyst um so here you
see an example of a very simple chemical
reaction network model called the
originator
and so this is a simple model that
oscillates so here i built it using the
dsl and here i just simulated it
using the um
using the
you know the same kind of notation that
we've seen before using differential
equation dot jails sit five solver and
you see we get an oscillatory chemical
reaction network um in this case
now what i'd like to show you now is
another way to build it uh using the
symbolic tooling that's built into
modeling toolkit and symbolics.jl
which can give us some more flexibility
so we're going to build the same exact
model but going symbolically instead of
via the dsl and then we'll start to see
how that lets us do some other advanced
features um so here i'm going to specify
my parameters so i'm creating symbolic
five symbolic parameters for the
reaction rates and here i'm specifying
my species amounts and the time variable
as variables so these macros have now
created julia
symbolic parameters and julius symbolic
variables that i can manipulate
so for example and again this is all
built on top of some the the julia
computer algebra algebra system
symbolics.jl so for example if i take x
i can build a rational uh
function from it you know x squared
minus 2x plus 1 over x minus 1
and then i can simplify that expression
and it factors it and
and it'll eliminates the denominator um
and then if i want i could do
substitution so i can say replace x
minus 1 with y and it will substitute it
out so this really shows you that i'm
just doing everything on top of the
normal computer algebra system that's
represented by symbolics.jl but for our
purposes we're going to think of the k's
as our rates and the x's and the y's as
our species variables
and now
using the symbolic interface we can
construct our reactions in the following
way we build julia
here reaction is just a normal julia
structure
uh i actually don't remember i think
it's a it's a regular structure it's an
immutable structure
and we basically just create a reaction
with some input so here i specify the
rate or the rate expression this could
be k1 times t if i wanted my rate to
grow in time um or it could be k1 times
x if i wanted to have another factor of
x in the rate
i give a list of the substrates of the
reaction and a list of the products of
the reaction and if there are no
substrates or no products i just say
nothing so in this case the first
reaction i have an x and a y and i make
nothing and if you don't at that point
the assumption is that the substrates
and products have stoichiometry
coefficients of one so all of these get
coefficients of one
if i want to use other stoichiometry
coefficients then i get to give a five
argument form so here i have a substrate
x with coefficient one i have a product
x and a product z with coefficients two
and one and that gives me this third
reaction here
and so i make a vector of these five
reactions
here you can see how they're represented
and these are now five symbolic
reactions that we're storing uh we've
created
um and now um from those i can then
build a reaction system just like we
would build via the dsl and there's
actually a third way to do it that's a
hybrid if you want to still have the
nice way of typing reactions that the
dsl does but you want to build these
individual reaction objects because say
you're writing a program and you want to
build them in a loop or something you
can use the at reaction macro so this
builds just one reaction object instead
of a whole reaction system which is what
the reaction network macro builds so
here i built each of my five reactions
using the same notation um that we use
in the regular dsl
and you can check by just testing equal
equal that the two reaction lists i get
are exactly the same in these two cases
so i've built these five reactions in
two different ways
and now we're ready to build our system
so now i just create a reaction system
passing in my vector of reactions and
the time variable the symbolic time
variable and i'm going to name it
organator just like i did in the dsl
and if i check remember up uh
here
i created the variable rn and i named it
the network organator
um
if i check is rn equal to the one i just
built
symbolically here sure enough they're
equal
okay and the key thing about the
equality is the equality requires that
you give them the same name so when you
say at named here
um it sets the internal name of the
reaction system to the name of the
variable you type if you wanted to give
it a different name you could use the
name keyword argument and i could have
said
rn2 equals reaction system rxst name
originator this would make a reaction
system with the name organator but
stored in the variable rn2
but in either case as long as you give
them the same internal name these will
be the same exact systems catalyst will
check are all the reactions and species
and parameters the same
so this gives us a fully symbolic way to
construct our reaction network
from a more programmatic interface than
using the dsl
so let me show you some of the cool
things that that enables and the first
is parametric stoichiometry so suppose i
want to have a protein that gets made
with that's produced uh from
transcription in random bursts so
there's a rate k that the protein gets
produced and when it's produced a random
amount of them m is produced so m here
is a random variable in particular m
will be a shifted geometric random
variable um so it's a geometric random
variable whose smallest value is one
and then our protein can also degrade
let's see how we can actually build that
model symbolically so here i specify my
parameters and there's three parameters
there's the rate that i make the protein
there's the rate the protein degrades
away
and then there's a symbolic parameter
that i use in my geometric random
geometric distribution to set the mean
burst size so i need to know what's the
average amount of m that gets produced
and b is going to be our symbolic
parameter that we'll use to set that
we have one variable the p of t time is
already defined otherwise i would make t
a variable too
and now i want to use
we have a way to make m a geometric
random variable the way we'll do that is
we'll make it a sample from
distributions.jl's geometric
distribution so here i pull in the
geometric distribution
and then i'm going to just set that m is
a random number sampled from the
geometric distribution with parameter
one over b my symbolic parameter that
sets the mean plus one because i want it
to be a shifted geometric so it always
starts at one
unfortunately if you do this you're
gonna get an error and the error you're
going to get is the following it's going
to say you tried
you tried to use a non-boolean num in a
boolean context and the problem here is
that the function geometric of one over
b
it can't take a symbolic variable as
input the way it's coded it only works
with floating point numbers so some
julia functions because of the magic of
multiple dispatch will work with a
symbolic variable others won't so how
can we make it work well luckily for us
symbolics.jl has a cool feature where
you can tell it
uh to register this function and when
you do that it won't actually ever try
to pass b the symbolic b into it instead
it'll just in your final code replace
the symbolic b with the floating point b
and your final simulation code so it
handles letting you use the function
without ever trying to call it with a
symbolic variable
so i do this to basically make it usable
and now i can create a symbolic variable
m that just calls the geometric
distribution with my symbolic parameter
b or one over b um the way that uh it's
defined in distributions.jl takes a
sample a random sample from it and adds
one to that okay
so this will be my random variable for
the number of proteins that get produced
during a given transcription event and
now i can just make my reactions the
normal way so i create a reaction
that says from nothing i make protein at
rate k and the stoichiometry or the
number of proteins i make is m is this
geometric random variable i defined and
then p can degrade to nothing at rate
gamma
i can build a reaction system from that
list of reactions uh in this way i give
it the list of the two reactions i give
it the time and now i've built a
reaction system with this bursty
production of protein
and i can go and simulate it just like
before so i specify a mapping for the
parameters the values of the rate that
i'm making protein
the value of the rate that protein gets
degraded and this parameter b that sets
the average burst size
of the average number of m that gets
produced in a given transcription event
i set my initial condition for the
amount of protein i have at time zero
and then just like we've seen a bunch of
times at this point i can go through and
simulate it using ssa stepper and
gillespie's direct method
and i can go through simulated and plot
it and i just wanted to show you there's
a few ways we can plot it so
when you go to plot it
if you remember earlier
torkle showed us how if we know the
index of a species we can plot using its
index uh but modeling toolkit
actually allows us to plot using the
symbolic variable for the species in a
few different ways
so here's one way
i plot my solution that i get
so here i solve it and i return that
solution
and i set the variable i want to plot to
be my gene network model my reaction
systems p variable so burstygene.p
and that will plot that specific
solution component so i can use this
type of indexing to get at symbolic
variables and not have to know their
actual index in the solution object or
solution vector and here you see we have
kind of a long time where nothing
happens then we get a burst of protein
meat a long time a burst of protein a
degradation and so on and we get these
kind of bursty production events as time
goes on
another way that we can do it that's
completely equivalent is we can take our
reaction system our bursty gene and we
can load the symbolic protein variable p
from it using this unpack command so
this just takes the the network and says
load into my current environment the
symbolic variable p from it and then i
can plot using that and i get the same
exact plot
finally
if i don't have access to my reaction
system that has all the symbolic
information suppose i just have the
solution which doesn't have that
symbolic information i can just create
as long as i know the name i can create
a variable from scratch using the sim
the modeling toolkit at variables
command and i can just use that and
it'll still pull out the right one and
plot the right one so in this way i
don't have to try to worry about what's
the index of species b in my solution
vector what's the index of parameter
alpha in my in my parameter vector
instead i can use the actual symbolic
variable for plotting and for accessing
the solutions which is what i'm showing
here
so if for example i wanted to evaluate
the solution at a bunch of times
here i'm making 10 times between 0 and 1
and i wanted to get the value of p at
those times i can just take my solution
so remember
here bursty solution is the solution the
ssa solution the gillespie method
solution
i evaluated at those times and i tell it
the index i want is my symbolic variable
p
and i get out this recursive array
diffieq array but if i look at u dot u
that's the exact solution of my problem
at the times i picked and u dot t is the
times that i picked
okay so in that way i can use the
symbolic variables to do indexing of the
solution too which makes calculations
easier um
okay
so that was kind of just a little quick
and dirty on how you can use those to
kind of plot it
now i just showed you how we can make a
um apparent use parametric stoichiometry
via the symbolic form to make bursty
make and simulate bursty reactions but
you might say yeah but it's kind of
annoying to have to type at parameters
at variables and type in all these
individual reactions
and here's some good news for you we
figured out and we've got an interface
where you can combine the simplicity of
the dsl with the symbolic features for
just the things you need to do
symbolically and that's what i'm showing
here
so here
there's no way in the dsl to create a
stoichiometry
variable that's a random gm that's a
geometric random variable
so i create that symbolically the same
way i just did above but then i just
interpolated into the dsl
to use it um
in
to use it in the dsl itself so what this
says is basically uh i'm making my two
reactions zero goes to m times p p goes
to nothing and i want to
put in for the stoichiometric
coefficient of p
this symbolic variable m that i
previously defined
okay so in this way we can kind of very
nicely
and compactly define the reaction system
and just do symbolically the one piece
that needs to be done symbolically and
if you check this gene that i created
this way is completely this reaction
network model is completely equivalent
to the one that we created earlier
purely
symbolically
sorry about the phone call that was
actually probably my niece wanting to
play video games so but uh
this is more fun for me right now so
okay um
so
the
um so that's kind of an alternative way
to build the system and this kind of
interpolation thing works very generally
and if you want to see how to do this
more generally you can look in the um in
the catalyst documentation but if you
want to create a complicated expression
for the rate constant say a function
with a lot of stuff you can define it
symbolically and then you know you could
define that k is
sine of m times you know exp of minus m
or something and then in here you could
say dollar k and that would interpolate
in that expression and use that to
define the rate constant of the reaction
um and so in that way you can kind of
very nicely combine the two models
together the two approaches together to
kind of minimize what you have to type
and hopefully make it more readable
okay and maybe i'll skip that okay
so i had two more things that i wanted
to tell you about in terms of the
symbolic features one is called
compositional modeling
so it's the ability to define a whole
bunch of um
of um
separate reaction networks and then mix
them together and the application i'll
show you in a minute is to build a bunch
of genes and hook them together into a
gene network that we can simulate
and then i want to show you how we can
extend our models with odes or algebraic
equations that are not coming from
chemical reactions to kind of broaden
what we can model with catalyst
so compositional modeling we have two
functions that come from modeling
toolkit that we can hook into extend
lets us take two networks and merge them
together
and compose which takes a network and
sits it as a sub network within another
a subsystem of another and i just wanted
to illustrate this on some very simple
examples um so here suppose i make a
network a that's encodes a plus b goes
to c and i make a second network that
encodes c goes to a plus b
if i extend the two together then i get
a new network that has both the
reactions in it okay so it's like just
merging them together it's basically
like a merge command um and so this is a
useful way to define components of a
reaction system or reaction network and
then kind of compositionally compose
them together into bigger networks
um
likewise though we can also kind of
build tree structures where networks are
attached to each other hierarchically
and they don't live at the same level um
so here let's build one more network uh
rn3 which is my newest reaction network
which is a plus d goes to 2d so now i've
got three networks i've got rn1 that's a
plus b goes to c r n2 which is c goes to
a plus b
and rn3 which is a plus d goes to 2d
and so suppose i take
this network and i
compose the other two into it so i take
my base network and i compose the other
two into it
what this does is it sets them up as sub
systems
that live below it okay and notice when
it shows me the reactions
now they get these names for the network
they come from and the key thing here is
that
uh reaction network's two c variable is
not assumed to be the same as the c
variable in the top level network the
compose network which i call base rn
that was the variable name
in the same way that rn
3's
reaction network 3's a variable is not
the same as the top a variable is not
the same as this a variable so this is a
this is what's called name spacing in
modeling toolkit it allows me to have a
bunch of networks that i hook together
hierarchically
and their variables will be treated as
different if i want them to be treated
as the same i have to do some special
things so in this composed model i've
actually got one two three four five six
seven eight different species uh that it
encodes these are all treated as
different species
um
and you can plot these kind of
structures using this tree plot command
very nicely um
and there's lots of ways to manipulate
these and deal with these i haven't
really talked about this today but
modeling toolkit and catalyst have lots
of api functions for getting at the
species and the parameters and these
subs these are called subsystems so you
can get the two subsystems out of the
compose network by calling the
getsystems command and you can look at
their name and see it's rn2 and rn3 like
i showed here
and so in this way you can build these
big hierarchical tree structure networks
and i'll show you an example with like i
said in a minute with the gene network
but when there's an important thing you
need to be aware of though which is that
when you convert your reaction system
into odes or sds or jump processes
catalyst has to merge these all into one
single network it has to get rid of the
hierarchical structure and that's called
flattening
and so there's a command
catalyst.flatten that gets called when
you create ode problems or ode systems
that merges them all together
but it makes sure to keep the names that
indicate what system the variable came
from okay and so if i look at the
species in the flattened network like i
said there's eight species and these
include the c's and a's that come from
the subsystems
likewise if i look at the parameters i
see three parameters including the
parameters that came from the subsystems
and if i look at the reactions i see the
reactions that came from the subsystems
they've all been merged together at this
point okay so that's kind of the notion
or the idea of this compositional
modeling is to build these kind of
hierarchies and you can see this all in
a lot more detail in the compositional
modeling tutorial of the catalyst stocks
so let's look at an example of the
represelator which is a gene network of
three genes gene one gene two g3 where
gene one inhibits gene two gene two
inhibits gene three and gene three
inhibits gene one so they form kind of a
circle that inhibit each other and so
i'm going to make a little function here
that uses catalyst to make one gene of
the system the function will take as
input the name of that gene
and a variable a symbolic variable
corresponding to who's going to repress
that gene so the assumption is going to
be that each gene can be repressed via
repressive hill interaction
so this function takes the repressor as
input and then it builds the gene
uh where there's a repressive hill
interaction from that i'll set some
default values for my parameters and a
default value for my initial conditions
and then this will return a single gene
in my network
and now what i'm going to do is make
three of these and hook them together to
make the represso later um so the first
thing i have to do is i have to specify
by hand
um
the
for the the repressor of the first gene
i need to create a variable that
corresponds to the repressor of the
first gene so how am i going to do that
well i'm going to create this variable
which says the repressor of the first
gene is going to be
uh
the protein that's made by gene 3. okay
and the plus here is to indicate it
comes from gene three you can type that
it's unicode so you type slash
underscore plus and then you hit a tab
at least you should hit a tab there we
go and that will give you that unicode
plus that lets you indicate that i'm
creating a variable from the system
being three
and then i create gene one by calling my
repressed gene function and passing in
this variable that's the repressed
protein from gene three
and this parent scope says that the way
you get access to the it says that this
variable is not going to live in gene
one in that network it's going to live
it's going to be accessible from the
parent network that stores gene one and
we'll see more about that in a minute
okay
um
here i make gene two and for gene two
since i've already made gene one i can
just say g1.p to access its protein and
say that's the repressor and then again
we access that by going up to the parent
and then accessing g1 via the parent
and then i make gene 3
by again sending in that the repressor
is g2's protein
going up to the parent and accessing it
in that way and so now i've got three
gene network three genes each repressed
by a specific
repressor that i chose and i can hook
them together
in this way so i create a reaction
system or i could have used the compose
command again
and i say that my reaction system is
going to have three subsystems the first
gene the second gene and the third gene
which gives me this big set of reactions
okay
and so the way to kind of visualize this
is i have my three genes and my
repressor later is a system sitting
above them that stores them and so when
i wanna get at the repressor for gene
two i go up to the parent and then i
access g1.p that's why i had to use the
parent scope command it said get at that
variable by going to the parent system
okay
um and now
i can actually go and simulate my whole
system
so
i have to break the symmetry in the
default values i gave i set the initial
amount of all the protein to zero so for
the od model i break the symmetry by
saying gene one has 20 proteins
initially i set my time span i create an
ode problem
and i solve it
i didn't need to set any other initial
conditions or parameter values because i
set them as defaults earlier up and sure
enough we see our composed system
oscillates and we get the classical
repressor later where gene one comes up
and then it starts going down as the
next one comes up i guess gene one is in
is in
purple
green so you see as the green gets
higher it starts shutting off the second
one but as the second one gets shut off
the third one goes up and shuts off the
first one and so you get a natural
iteration or cycle between the three of
them
so
okay
so that was kind of a quick tour of um
compositional modeling so the last thing
i wanted to show you before torquel will
take back over and show us a bit about
bifurcations is how we can add in um
non-reaction odes or algebraic equations
and i wanted to show you this with the
classical hodgkin-huxley equations so of
course catalyst is great for modeling
and simulating chemical reaction systems
but sometimes we have other variables
that we want to evolve via odes to that
are coupled in like maybe the volume of
my domain should change in time via an
ode and so i need to write an equation
for that um
likewise
i may i may for example when modeling
neurons i may have three chemical
reactions for the ion channels but i may
also have an ode for the transmembrane
potential which we'll call v of t that's
the electrical potential across the
membrane of my neuron and so that's the
model we're going to be build now so
we're going to have three basic chemical
states
corresponding to the three ion channels
i should say corresponding to two ion
channels sodium and potassium and they
can flip open or close so here m is
going to be essentially the fraction of
open m type um gating variables n is the
fraction of open n n-type h is the
fraction of open h-type and they flip
back and forth from the closed state
which i'll put a prime on to the open
state with the rate alpha s
to flip open and beta s to flip close so
there's an alpha m that's the rate that
you flip from the m prime state where
your
your
m channel is inactivated to the open
version of it
there's an n prime that's that's
represents that the n gating variables
are inactivated and they can flip open
with the rate alpha n and so on and so
forth and these rates will depend on the
voltage so as the
transmembrane potential changes
these rates will change so they'll be
functions of this other ode that
represents the transmembrane potential
and so in the catalyst model i'm going
to have six variables m n h
m prime m n prime h prime for activated
and inactivated gating variables that
you can flip between
and now here i'm just defining all my
transition functions my probability for
time that the channels flip open and
closed so here's alpha m here's beta m
here's alpha h here's beta h and so on
alpha n beta n
um and i'm using
instead of using an if else statement
i'm using this if else package so if
the value of this parameter theta is
zero it returns one otherwise it returns
theta over one minus e to the theta the
reason i'm using this special if else
command is because that makes these um
these functions work in automatic
differentiation so if we wanted to throw
this into higher level applications that
needed to use automatic differentiation
having these functions would allow it to
work actually it'll work sorry symbolic
differentiation
so it makes it work better
from the symbolic perspective so that's
why i'm including these if-else commands
so that's all my rate functions for
flipping states
now i create a symbolic variable that's
the voltage or the transmembrane
potential and i give it this special tag
in modeling toolkit this is called
metadata
okay so i'm attaching to this the
metadata that it is an is bound is bc
species is true so this means that the
voltage is going to be considered by
catalyst as what's called a boundary
condition species
that's a terminology that comes from
spml and it just means
that v may appear in reaction terms but
we don't generate an ode from it so
we're going to give it its own equation
somewhere else we're not going to give
it any equations from the chemistry so
by setting this catalyst knows don't
create an equation for it in the
chemistry
so now i can create my model for my
channels flipping back and forth and you
see it looks a lot like what i wrote
above i say that the rate that i
transition from the inactive end state
to the active end state is alpha n of v
and i just interpolate in this v
variable that i created and then this is
the rate that i transition from the
active end state to the inactive state
okay so in this way i've created a
catalyst reaction network that has all
my transitions they look kind of ugly
because it's substituting in these
functions up here
but it's really just these
these six reactions that i wrote up here
using s for those three
finally now we've got all our chemistry
defined but we'd like to attach to this
an ode for how v changes specifically
this ode so that we can do by building
an ode system in modeling toolkit and
adding it to our catalyst model as a
constraint and so that's what i'm doing
here so i'm going to define a whole
bunch of parameters that the
hodgkin-huxley equation for how the
voltage change is needs so this is the
transmembrane potential oh sorry the
capacitance
this is the maximal conductance of
sodium channels maximal conductance of
potassium channels maximal conductance
of a leakage channel this is your
reversal potential for sodium to
channels and so on um and i'm also going
to define an input current so i'm i want
to have a way to stimulate my neuron in
the ode to give it a shock to set it off
so i create an action potential so i'm
going to give a sinusoidal input
here this is my input
with an amplitude i zero and i'm
initially going to set i zero to zero so
that there is no input so that my neuron
doesn't keep firing and later i'll turn
this on and allow it to fire
periodically
then i specify a differential with
respect to t which is what i've done
here
and i can set that my differential of v
with respect to t is the hodgkin-huxley
equation so it's minus 1 over the
membrane capacitance times the current
from the potassium channel plus the
current from the sodium channel plus a
leakage current plus my injected current
and i create a modeling toolkit ode
system and that's what i return up here
and i call it voltage ode
and so here you can see the actual ode
that gets generated which is the
classical hodgkin-huxley equation for a
neuron so now i've got these two pieces
i've got my reaction system with my six
reactions that tell me how my gaiting
variables open and close and i've got an
ode system for how my transmembrane
potential changes how do i combine them
together
well i just take my reaction model and i
extend it with the ode model that i
created and that gives me a
hodgkin-huxley model so now i've
composed the two together i've combined
them together and we've added this ode
for the voltage in as a constraint to
our hodgkin-huxley model
so now we've got a reaction system that
internally has a coupled ode system for
the voltage
and we're ready to actually start
simulating so first let's figure out the
steady state so we can start our neuron
at rest so that's what i'm doing here
i'm picking a big time interval i'm
picking uh just a made-up initial
condition and i'm now
solving the model out to a long time and
you see i actually even with my made up
initial condition i get an action
potential for the voltage notice i'm
only plotting vars equals v the symbolic
variable for the voltage the
transmembrane potential so here i get my
action potential and now if i take the
value of this solution at the final time
that is the steady state resting value
of my neuron so it's the steady state
value of v and m and h and so on
so i pull that out
from the solution i just take the
solution at the very end and now i've
got for all my variables their steady
state values and i'm now going to turn
back on my applied current
so i get that coefficient of the applied
current remember this was the amplitude
of the applied current i pull it out i
set it to be 10 now instead of zero so i
have a periodic sinusoidal current
or sine squared current i set my initial
value to be the steady state i just
pulled out i solved my ode problem and
now i get a whole series
a periodic series of action potentials
firing with both the chemistry and the
transmembrane potential being simulated
uh
via differential equations.jl
and so catalyst has this kind of nice
setup where you can kind of combine
things together it doesn't work for all
models so right now you can't do this
kind of composition uh to make jump
process models with coupled odes but
that's where we're headed long term and
it certainly works with odes and it may
work with sds i haven't tested it too
much yet
but if this is something of interest to
you we'd love issues if you play around
with it and things work or don't work if
you let us know either way
okay and i think that was my very long
section there i'll turn it back over to
torquel to change gears and tell us
about how we can do bifurcations in
catalyst now
yeah
okay
i see if i can
successfully add all of the streams and
stuff
do things seems to work
so really in this section
excellent
two packages i want to show
one is a bifurcation kit and the other
one is called homophobic contonation
and these are two julia packages which i
think we're like really really lucky to
have within the community uh which
allows us to do some really cool stuff
and they're both related to uh finding
steady states uh of biochemical well
in this case the steady state of
biochemical reaction networks uh but
both walls have wide replication
uh so start with a bifurcation kit
which i'm going to here use to
find bifurcation diagrams
uh but i also recommend uh to just check
circuit breaking kit julia and you will
see the package and it can really do
lots and lots of really fancy stuff
so in principle what we have in
bifurcation diagram we want to track how
the steady states of the system
uh
change through some parameter
so if you consider an od
system and if we were to simulate it for
a long time what typically happens is
that we reach some steady state and the
system rests there
and that's where all of the dx d t d y d
t et cetera et cetera is equal to zero
so the system did not change anymore
and bifurcation kit allows us to like
find how does this steady states uh
change
with whatever parameter
and i'm gonna use the same model as we
used before for the simulations this
positive feedback model
we previously saw that the model seems
to have two different steady states one
for low x concentration and one for high
and we show that
reaching this high steady state requires
to change this parameter i the input
parameter
so what i now want to do is to find how
does the steady states
get affected by the value of this
parameter i
so the first step this is a little bit
convoluted but basically i need to
transform this model into something
which bifurcation kit can read so
bifurcation kit is not really part of
the scientific machine learning
ecosystem
however i think
specific support is
being worked on
so for a couple of months you don't
actually have to do this step you can
pretty much just call make bifurcation
diagram this kind of model
and
so first what we have to do is we have
to convert to an od function
uh from this model to something called
the ud form
and we have to get an f function so the
actual re function and the j function
which is the jacobian
and then we get this jet
thing which will be the input to
bifurcation yet
but this is you can copy paste this and
do this with whatever model here you
have plug it in there you get out this
yet and you're going to use it in there
next we have to set the parameter values
uh so these are the parameter values uh
for which it won't do the bifurcation
diagram now of course that parameter
here i is going to be changed so the
value here doesn't really matter but the
other one is going to be fixed
and here i'm just going to specify the
index or the parameter which i want to
bifurcation with respect to in this case
i is the first parameter
and one thing i hope when i have like
specific support for bifurcation kit
inside ml is that you could just instead
specify something like this
but now we are set first and then a
parameter span which is the span over
which we want to do bifurcation diagram
and here when i plot my bifurcation
diagram i just want to say which the
concentration of each variable in the
steady state do i want to plot there are
of course one of one species so the only
only option is one
and bifurcation diagram also
qualification kit also allows you to
have function of the various states in
the system
and then i hear like
so and i might go into why but
when we do the bifurcation diagram
uh
we're gonna start with this set here so
i want to change so the value of
the target parameter in this case the
first one is also the value of the first
in this span
so i create a copy of these parameter
sets not to modify it and then i set
the parameter one
and the first parameter to be qualified
in a parameter set in a par time spawn
and finally i have to provide a guess
for the initial conditions
at the initial parameter set
so at this parameter set here
and this can be a very rough guess i
think this this guess is not i think
this is all off by an order of magnitude
but i have to write something
and then i write this continuation
parameter object
which basically is options
to bifurcation kit
so it takes quite a few options uh and i
can abandon them up and provide them
here
so p mean
is going to be the value
of
this is just the minimum parameter value
which is just
this thing here
and p max is the maximum value in
parameter span
then we have dsmax and dsmin and which
is basically like the stepping
and so we're gonna step
uh in the bifurcation diagram uh four or
p value
and this is basically like what is the
longest step we're gonna make and what
is a smaller step and here i can i
select to arbitrary one and then this ds
is just going to be the initial step
we're going to start with and i usually
like it's not too
important but you should select
something in between these two
and one important thing here is that
i can have a minus here and this kind of
selects the direction
and if for some reason say i want to
start at this final point so i want to
set like here we start at one
and then we're gonna go
from one to zero
then i would have to have a minus sign
here but using this notebook here i just
say okay ds there's to be like a
positive number and we're going from low
to high value
and this detect purification
basically say do we want to detect
bifurcation points
and then i calculate my verification
diagram there are several functions for
doing this the simplest one is using
this bifurcation diagram function
but there's some other ones for more
advanced
continuations
and again my yet object my u node object
my parameter values
this thing here basically says that i
want to do with respect to the first
parameter
remember this is equal to one
[Music]
here we have
this basically gives my output
this is some tangent i'll algorith is a
few different one this one usually works
and record from solution basically says
what we want to output and here i want
to just
select my output vector at
the plot variable so as the
concentration of one
and this basically say i don't want to
provide lots of output when i run it
and again
go to bifurcation
for more details uh and in practice
there are tons and tons of consideration
with running these bifurcation diagrams
so not always this default caption is
going to work and you have to do some
tuning
and i will show some basic uh things
that you need to like think about
uh but
yeah if you want to advance one just
check that one and you can do a lot of
really cool stuff anyway here we
calculate the bifurcation diagram
and then we just plot it using plot
this output thing here
and here we see that here we see the x
concentration as a function of the
parameter in this case the input between
zero and one
and we see that we go from
low concentration here to a high
concentration here so i have this
bistable switch
we have a monostay
monostable inactive state there were two
stables to the state and have a single
one when active and the bifurcation
points here
are marked here's the blue ones
and this is full bifurcation points but
we can detect other ones as well
and the stable steady states here are
marked for the slightly thicker line and
unstable one is the thin one say one
unstable steady state and here we have
stable ones
now
there's a few uh things i want to say
here like for example one
here say that instead select the time
span the parameter span 0 to 0.2
so i only compute this part of the
bifurcation diagram
i'm going to start in this point and
then i track left and here i end
and we can see here that
here we miss this quite a lot
so this part is still part of the
bifurcation diagram
but if you use this bifurcation diagram
uh function to calculate it you're just
gonna track from this initial point and
continue
and
and this means that you won't be able to
start find this your own trajectories
uh so i'm gonna have like one example
uh
and i'm gonna see
i'm gonna
try and check the
change which screen i show
so
try to move that add a stream
and
stop i'm gonna share a different one
and
share and let's see if this works
so say that we have a bifurcation
diagram like this
and where these two things doesn't
connect
and if i then start in this point here
and
work myself here i will never be able to
find
this part of the bifurcation diagram
and there are like you can use deflated
continuation and stuff to do this one as
well
but here i just wanted to show the
simple example
however what we have in this case we
have something like this and then we can
find the entire thing
so
i'm gonna go
back
and
shy what was previously sharing
okay
uh so so this is like a thing that you
need to think about and this year to
show that
this is quite a complex software like
you can do basic ones like this
but and if you want to do really cool
stuff you cannot do by vocational
spatial systems for example
and but then you really have to explore
what the pictures can do
and it's really amazing package i can't
recommend it enough
and then we have the second package and
which also an external package called
homotype continuation
and basically what homo continuation
does
it's a package for solving
a polynomial system so say that you have
a multivariate polynomial
and another system of those so for
example you have
three polynomials in three different
variables
and this lets you find the roots total
so we all know that we have one
polynomial in a single para variable uh
we can find a limit to how number of
solutions there are and we can find all
of them
and typically just like finding the
solutions to equations is quite a hard
problem so i've give you an arbitrary
functions
just being certain to say like oh yeah i
find all of the
solutions to this equation you can't
just do it but we're dealing with
no males
we can do it and using homo confirmation
if we're dealing with multivariate
polynomial systems where the n
polynomials as with n variables we can
find all of the solution
and what is nice here that is if we have
ordinary differential equations
generated
from chemical reaction network models
these will almost always be polynomial
systems
unless you like add some thin stuff even
if you have like for example
michaelis-menten functions
that's going to give you a rational
polynomial which can be reduced a
polynomial system so if you can solve
polynomial systems you can find the
steady state of chemical reaction
networks
and this really homophobic recognition
lets us do
so here i have like a model from a 229
paper uh and it's not uh particularly
exciting but what it is is a model we
have uh it can be bistable
and that means that there are several
steady states
and if only have one steady state of
course we can just run a simulation
until we like find the steady state but
if we have several steady states it's
more difficult
so what i do i declare my model
i declare some parameter values
and again here i won't go into much
detail but
if you want you can just uh copy paste
this for whatever system you have so i
convert do this i create a non-linear
system
here i kind of sub in the parameter
values so these parameter values
and then i kind of convert this into
something which is a little bit easier
for multiple conjugation to see
and then i use this as polynomial which
is basically our symbolics function
which
lets you consider an only like a set of
a symbolic expression as a real
polynomial so you can use polynomial
methods which include homotopic
homotypic continuation
i run this and how much
continuation.solve
on these equations
and then i use this thing here to say
that i want to check the real solutions
so of course we're going to find a lot
of solutions they're going to have
imaginary a part
which we're not very interested in when
dealing with chemical reactions because
you can't have imaginary species
concentration
and here we see we get
three different solutions so i have a
system with three free steady states
which is actually not trivial to find
otherwise but for multiple combination
let's just do this
and again
i really like encourage you to like
check out the package
your search
almost
innovation
uh
julia you find the github page and you
can read all about it
and you
like you have to do this thing you can
copy and paste this
and it will reliably always find
the various steady states
uh or i should note in this case it's
fine but sometimes
here we filter out the imaginary
solutions but we're still going to have
solutions which might have negative
numbers
and of course we need to filter away
this as well because you can't have
negative concentrations
uh so yeah
this is another packages and again like
yeah using these two packages you can
really find some cool stuff
and here again there's an exercise if
people are interested
and then i think i will leave to sam
who might have time to quickly go
through the last part i hope
i do thank you perfect i think it's it's
just enough time um
okay so in the in the last few minutes i
just wanted to tell you a bit about some
of the network analysis functionality we
have in catalyst and we have an enormous
amount of this that's covered in
the catalyst tutorials there's a network
analysis tutorial
i just wanted to show you one piece so
the piece i'm going to show you is
detection and elimination of
conservation laws
but you can also calculate stoichiometry
matrices and rate law vectors you can
calculate what are called linkage
classes and deficiencies of networks and
whether networks are weakly reversible
so there's all kinds of things we've got
built in but there's not really time to
go through it today
so let's talk a little bit about
conservation laws so if i have just the
system a plus b reversibly goes to c
then probably everyone or hopefully most
of you if we look at this we'll say
you know i don't really have three
independent variables here because the
amount of a's and b's are very related
to the amount of c's and in particular
if i know the amount of a and how much i
had of everything initially i can figure
out the amount of b's in the amount of
c's that's called the conservation law
so d a d t will equal db dt will equal
minus dc dt for this system
so that's something we're going to
exploit in a minute um
so first if i just take this system and
i set some default values for my
parameters and my initial conditions
and i convert it to a non-linear system
i get this set of equations for the
steady state and you can already see
there's a bit of an issue because this
is not a linearly independent set of
equations these are basically the same
equation written three times so if i
want to solve for steady states i'm
going to end up from this equation
getting an infinite set of solutions i'm
not going to get a specific solution
and that's a problem and we can try it
suppose we load homotomy continuation
and do what torquel just showed us we'll
get an error that homeotope continuation
can't calculate a steady state for this
system okay and the problem is because
there's an infinite set of steady states
because of because it's uh because of
the conservation law that's hidden in
here
so what we can do with catalyst is we
can actually calculate the conservation
laws and remove those variables reduce
the size of the system so that now we
get a single equation for one of the
variables a b or c that can be solved
and that's what i just wanted to show
you very quickly
so just calling the conservation laws
command on our reaction network goes and
internally calculates all the
conservation laws of the system so here
we get out a matrix that says this is a
this is b this is c so one conservation
law is that minus a plus b is a constant
this tells us the other conservation law
is that a plus c is a constant
if we call conserved equations we can
actually see
variables that catalysts will eliminate
to get rid of those redundant steady
state equations so here it's telling us
that it can eliminate b by saying b is a
plus the constant for the first
conservation law and c is the constant
for the second conservation law minus a
and what are those constants well those
constants if we look at conservation law
constants they're just the amount of b
minus the amount of a and the amount of
a plus the amount of c and how can we
calculate them since they're constants
we can just calculate them at time zero
and then know what they are so let's do
that so now i convert my co my reaction
system to a non-linear system and i tell
it remove the conservation laws so what
it's going to do is internally when it's
creating the nonlinear equations it's
going to eliminate b and c
and it's just going to give me an
equation for a
and that's exactly what we see here we
get one equation
0 is k minus times
this times this times this this is just
the equation for a in terms of my two
conservation law constants and those
constants can be calculated from the
initial condition
now we can go and do what torquel just
showed us
on the new system where we just have one
equation we can run homotopic
continuation and it tells us the steady
state so it spits it out
and just to show you that this is all
self-consistent here i've gone and i've
solved the original system to steady
state and plotted a
and then i put on at the end the steady
state that homotopia continuation gave
us
and sure enough that's what a is
converging to
you might be worried wait if we
eliminated b and c what if in my
simulations i need to use b maybe i want
to measure b squared or something that's
an important observable of the system
well conveniently catalyst and modeling
toolkit doesn't throw them away it just
makes them not be state variables
anymore they're converted into what's
called observables
and you can still access them in the
same way so if i wanted to say plot the
amount of b
i can take my system and unpack the
symbolic b variable and the symbolic c
variable and i can say plot those b and
c variables so even though they're no
longer unknowns of the system they're
now getting plotted and i can evaluate
them and get their values
and then here i've just plotted b plus c
so here i evaluated the solution at a
bunch of times
uh the solution for b at a bunch of
times and the solution for c had a bunch
of times and i added them up and i'm
plotting it just to show you that they
really are constant that really was a
conservation law
so this is one another nice feature that
catalyst has if you have a reaction
network where you have conserved
variables or species when you convert to
odes the jacobian of the system will be
singular
at steady state you'll generally get a
singular
and you'll get a set of equations that
are not linearly independent and that
will cause problems trying to solve for
steady states
or trying to do calculations involving
the jacobian so by using this remove
conserved
keyword catalysts will calculate the
conservation laws move them out of the
system so that everything becomes much
nicer much more nicely defined and works
better in these other higher level
applications but it doesn't throw away
those variables you can still calculate
and evaluate them in case you need that
for your own application
and i know that was kind of quick but
the notebooks are all posted at the link
that we gave at the start of the
presentation just go to the catalyst jl
website and it's linked there right now
so you can look at these notebooks and
torkles notebooks um
and that was actually everything i had
so let me bring torquel back on
oh
you added yourself and i removed you but
uh i just wanted to say thank you to all
to coming uh thank you torkel for
helping uh run this i hope this was uh
helpful and of use to some of you um if
you have questions uh you know you can
post them now on the pigeonhole site uh
unfortunately i can't access discord so
if anyone is asked questions on the
discord i for some reason discord is
locked to me um but if you have a
question
maybe torquel can figure out how to go
on there or i'm quickly making an
attempt to go to the discord or
otherwise please feel free um to post on
uh siamel bridged or diffieq bridged on
slack um or on zulip or open an issue on
catalyst we watch all those channels and
we're happy to hear from you uh and if
you have questions if you want to know
how to do something if there's
functionality we're missing that you
think we should have um
someone asked about spatial uh so you
don't need to ask are we planning
spatial yes in fact we have uh some
grants that are funding us to work
towards spatial um that's something that
i'm hopefully in the fall going to be
working on so hopefully we'll have some
spatial modeling functionality within
six months to a year um
but yeah and otherwise uh i think uh we
can stop it there
if you uh have questions feel free to
ask them if we see them
uh we'll answer them in the next couple
minutes uh and otherwise we'll end the
stream right at five on time so
i don't know were you able to get in uh
uh
okay
well
uh yeah frank frank chen if you want to
contact me you can you can message me on
slack the julia slack or you can email
me um if you just google my name samuel
isaacson my email is on my website so
but all right i think we should probably
why don't we end the stream there so
thanks again torkel thank you all for
coming
thanks everyone have a good rest of the
day wherever you're located